[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour
cette nouvelle partie du match de
championnat du monde Vlad c'est déjà la
sixième partie du match on arrive
presque à la moitié
bon yo yo la francophonie il est vrai en
est presque à moitié
à présent bah c'est toujours plus pour
en fait aujourd'hui y compris j'ai peur
hier on avait pu recul
aujourd'hui j'ai toujours peur mais
[Musique]
deux fois dans les parties de rapport
non une fois dans la partie de Richard
et une fois dans les parties d'autres
rapports donc sa femme
j'ai une question est-ce que c'est
simple là c'est pas mal réputé non
non non ça va non je pense que tu le
confondu avec
des quatre cavaliers
possible
3 grosse question si
il va opter pour cavaler ses 6 ou E6
parce que ce sont de
surveillants complètement différente
avec des idées différentes mais bien sûr
prévisible c'est bien prévisible
l'idée c'est d'embêter
et une grosse ligne avec les sacrifices
3 et maintenant soit photo 3 soit foot
ça c'est vraiment complexe et là c'est 4
à ma connaissance non parce que je pense
enfin non pas pour F5 plutôt un F5
peut-être avec les deux photos
il a fait CDE fouf ça ouais tu sais là
je suis un peu inquiet parce qu'il joue
comme moi avec les noirs
c'est pas les meilleurs des lignes
d'ailleurs parce que faut que
sans s'échanger sur D4 est plus
intéressant
de manière générale je me rappelle que
dans ces variantes là il vaut mieux
avoir le Cavaillon F8 quand tu as fait
C5 avant et que tu peux entamer le plan
avec E6 ou D6 et qui a lieu 7 et pas que
aussi
c'est les deux plans mais quand tu as le
cavalier en F6
généralement tu vas avoir un problème
avec fou B5 enfin un problème
Phobos 5 maintenant existe mais c'est
plutôt ces trois d'abord théoriquement
il y a pas de grandes choses donc C3 E6
et maintenant soit que le H4 ou soit
plutôt dans BO3 ok mais cette finale
genre c'est juste mieux pour les blancs
à long terme cette finale et le
fantastique pour lui
alors après dans votre réputation
c'est critique
je pense que j'ai eu cette position
contre camski avec le noir avec les deux
couleurs
et c'est quoi les résultats toujours mal
pour les blancs
mais en bide c'est trop facile à jouer
avec les Noirs ça veut dire que tu as
perdu avec les ventes à gagner avec eux
je pense
de toute manière un peu plus été surpris
quand qui vit une boire qui que ce soit
parce que je pense que tu es capable de
boire
ce que veut dire qu'il n'a pas vu ta
vidéo avec un million d'oviews non ça
veut juste dire que je suis tellement
devenu tellement fort là que les gens
savent pas comment on peut jouer aussi
bien
mais c'était un Londres aussi avec les
noirs et j'ai entamé un plan sympa il a
joué un plan avec H4 H5 du coup j'ai
fait H6 foot D7 6F 5 fois 8 et
finalement je me suis permis à un moment
donné juste de bouffer son
un peu trop avancé quand même
pas mal donc par contre peut-être mon
trône les lignes un peu plus facile
c'est toi aussi
pas faut décider
très important maintenant
il a fait ses trois en tout cas
je sais de me rappeler maintenant est-ce
que prévu ce que les H4 existe
voici je me rappelle plus en fait l'idée
faut que quatre dans deux trois dans
bouge 3 faut bouger 4 ça recommence
pareil non à chaque fois c'est ce truc
là qui pardon
qui s'entame non
ici non ici c'est une super version pour
les Noirs donc peut-être à l'heure qu'on
va aller H4 à cause justement de l'aider
avec faux faut des six ne marche pas
c'est tellement facile de confondre
ouais ouais
5 faut G4 et aussi avec CDD ou pas et à
chaque fois c'est différent en plus
quand elle est surjouit ou pas enfin
j'ai beaucoup étudié ça mais je peux pas
rentrer là-dedans
mais je trouve que le choix est
tellement mauvais pour les blancs
parce que ça c'est vraiment pas facile à
jouer avec les Blancs et surtout c'est
pas un avantage
malheureusement pour les blancs les
boivent doivent plus ou moins rentrer
dans ce complications parce que après
dans votre décision ça ne peut pas
continuer normalement en jouant au four
de 3 tandis que avec le fou sur G4 un
peu juste
comme ça et ça tu peux être content avec
les Blancs tu peux jouer longtemps par
rapport au standard de maintenant oui
sauf que les noirs on empoignent contre
lesquels il est très très dur de gagner
c'est trop beau
Jean et
trois
malgré les
je parlais les principes et tout juste
d'ailleurs je peux commencer je peux
commencer par cavalier de 7 au lieu de
28 et puis essayer de pousser quand même
5 et donc souffrir un petit peu me
concoie ça suffit pas enfant j'ai vu ou
pas mal des partenaires comme ça
j'essaie toujours de faire le même plan
dans ce truc là j'essaie de faire tout 3
tours 1 dame D1 B4 bon si besoin fermé
et après tout [__] là-bas justement
c'est pour ça qu'il est noir vu elle
rencontre ce point avec ça direct de la
gueule parce que ce plan là il est hyper
fort le problème c'est que les Blancs
ont l'initiative sur l'île du roi à long
terme très longtemps oui et c'est c'est
désagréable parfois tu peux même jouer
des finances tu peux même entamer des
plans avec F4 G4 H4 H5 le roi qui monte
en G3 il y a une très belle partie dans
cette structure là de fil rouge à
contre Girardo dans une structure comme
ça je te recommande de la regarder
furyza a gagné cette semaine il a joué
longtemps il a gagné une femelle
ah ok
mais il entamait un plan assez long où
il a fini par échanger des pièces ok
ramener les tours [__] son fou en C1
pour défendre les pions le pion à 3
l'autre a foutu son cavalier en C4 puis
il a tout poussé à l'ail droit ah j'ai
l'impression que il a gagné j'ai
l'impression
ok il a gagné parce que dans cette
finale il évolu l'occasion de pousser
sur le roi c'est pour ça
mais elle est assez facile à jouer cette
finale et tu peux la jouer longtemps
les coups de Londres puis dans une
déposition clé de cette de cette
ouverture là ça y est bah écoute mais de
quoi tu réfléchis maintenant soit tu
joues dans un BO3 maintenant soit au
lieu de se Troie il te faut choisir faut
pousser ça même de quoi tu réfléchis
3 E6 c'est Dame B3 à 100%. ouais
incroyable ce matin
parce que cavalier 5 tu dois jamais
avoir on peut toujours jeter un œil
non le problème c'est que ce dodo
enfin pas dans cette position là mais en
fait genre tu fais cavalier F3
et là l'autre veut faire un truc comme
cavalier des 7 bon là il y a qui prend
ses 6 qui marche il faudrait le faire
marcher mieux mais disons qu'il fasse je
sais pas moi Thor c'est 8 fullike
il est très cheap mais il fait toujours
très plaisir
[Rires]
je sais pas mais j'entraîne même pas le
joueur de te le dire chez qui ça marche
tu vois
parce que c'est pas assez forts
c'est un peu comme comment s'appelle
comment s'appelle ce match sur F7 le
mois de l'année
en poil plus compliqué
encore plus facile
ah ok tu fais ça le gars fait ça tu fais
ça il prend
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais ils font plaisir quand même
je sais pas quoi dire à vrai dire
pour une fois j'ai plus de bon
en tout cas tout le monde peut les
comprendre dans le chat et c'est ça qui
est bien ouais
de toute manière qu'est-ce que nous
attend ici alors donc
qu'est-ce que je suis mécontent de ce
premier coup là
ce que ok ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que si il rentre pas dans cette ligne
pour liker de toutes les violences pas
trop préparer
il va falloir dans votre
alors je dois me vanter que j'ai déjà
joué ce coup
il peut y avoir une petite idée qu'on
appelle ici la dollars
5 là le mec est fou fou il fait
et tu prends et tu fais quoi
[Rires]
ok je vais signifier un jour pour le
spectateur qui aura donc
l'autre je suis sage 4 c'est que gagne
aussi d'ailleurs j'ose plus loin parce
que le noir se renobliger de se voler le
fou avec H6 ou H5 que les G6 G est bon
au revoir
ouais
ça doit être plus doux comme ça
je me rappelle plus quel est le coup ici
ok l'amant veut faire pour des six
à part ça le Mans veut faire d'embêter
quel est ton idée si je joue
[Musique]
alors si je joue au foot
et tu menaces
c'est sûr enfin moi j'ai déjà joué au
blanc et au noir ce truc là j'ai jamais
vu au football
5 et pas se trompe c'est 4
pas forcément avec les blancs mais
peut-être avec les noirs
c'est vite fait de venir
je suppose
il est vrai ça permet de coller H4
d'ailleurs après collage
je pense que tu aimes bien
en quelque sorte je menace même
[Musique]
si tu fais fou de
il y a une finesse d'avoir attiré la
dame ici bah ok les Noirs réagissent pas
par exemple fossette
c'est pour voir
bon maman veut jouer avec H6 maman c'est
pas moi c'est maman
je sais pas pour quelle raison
d'ailleurs peut-être attends un peu plus
d'espace genre rock toi tu fais H5 je
sais pas
avec le noir j'aurais été très
content mais lui connaissait il a fait
des systèmes quoi
c'est un auteur
son chemin
ça peut être quoi l'idéal alors
la deuxième c'est oui et donc jouer les
structures certes dommage qu'on a pas la
case de Troie moi jouable
l'autre idée ça peut être alors au lieu
de ça de jouer que voler E5 petit rock
et bouffer sur ce 6 attends est-ce que
je peux me permettre de bouffer du Fou
oui bien sûr et faire B4
à cause d'un sondes
qu'il y aura beaucoup de dynamique pour
le noir ici c'est sûr je suis
complètement sûr
moi je suis pas sûr que je vais les
trouver mais je suis complètement sur
bon de toute façon la question se répond
pas il fait rock ouais mais c'est
tellement modeste comme prépa
il veut dire que hier tu as joué
rien d'autre d'ailleurs
mais sinon c'est vrai que c'est
impressionne pas trop quoi
est-ce qu'il va faire
j'ai eu des milliers de police de
milliers de parties comme ça mais ok tu
peux jouer et tout peut t'arriver mais
c'est rien quoi moi j'aime bien jouer
avec les Blancs personnellement mais
ça peut devenir quelque chose si tu
arrives de changer les fous quand il
[__] ton cavalier sur Detroit donc
ça veut dire que si tu je pars réussir
de un truc un peu fantaisiste
[Musique]
un peu mieux moi bien sûr il faut il
faudrait
prendre
deux tours
mais malheureusement c'est très loin de
dire ça par contre tu es intéressante ok
bien sûr là il va se requier sans
réfléchir
ça et aucun doute donc tu rentres et
puis intéressant qu'il sera le choix de
Yann je suppose
peut-être
possible
il faut comprendre en avance qu'est-ce
qui comment tu réagis sur coréens
bonjour il est quelle heure à Kazakhstan
4 heures plus quoi
bon après c'est hyper intéressant parce
qu'on va voir une position
juste un peu plus agréable pour les
blancs on va voir comment yann est
capable de jouer ça avec les Noirs parce
que là il y a même pas de théorie entre
guillemets intéressant pour toi parce
que tu es un spécialiste ici
depuis que j'ai beaucoup regardé E4
c'est 5 qui avait F3 qui est ici 4
[Musique]
c'est ça
des quatre tout ça
il n'y a pas longtemps avec ça dans un
tournoi
mais je connais loin
mais parmi les les
je parle pas de moi quoi parmi les forts
[Musique]
mais André King j'ai un bon score contre
lui je pense qu'il mène 6 4 ou peut-être
8 4 quelque chose comme ça
son style est pas mal pour moi
son style de ne rien faire et puis
sacrifier quelque chose
il envoie quelque chose très bizarre
ressemble un petit peu à ce pas qui quoi
qui est beaucoup moins en universel
m'a battu 8,5
je sais pas si ça compte en fait
quoi comme ça
pas l'impression d'avoir gagné quoi
mais non non en fait je l'ai contre
l'effort l'avantage que j'ai ce qui est
plus facile pour moi c'est que ils ont
pas trop peur de mes ouvertures et il se
rendent pas compte
que ça peut être dangereux
tu vois par exemple
c'est vraiment dangereux je sais pas si
tu l'as analysé c'est vraiment dangereux
si tu connais pas
terrible d'ailleurs je pense que je
comprends que le coup je refais avec le
nom
ici
content donc danse 7 moi je pense que
fort probable que c'est trop fort pour
rigoler tu sais pourquoi je t'ai dit que
gouiraro était pas très fort OK gouira
je l'ai demandé qui est le squat contre
celui-là
je dis bah
moins de
je dis ça veut dire il est dit quatre
parties j'ai gagné que deux fois
[Rires]
est-ce que sur dame c'est ça tu peux me
permettre français 6
j'ai un choix maintenant ok bosser et je
voulais maintenant réussir à faire ça et
il faut
est-ce que je peux me permettre si
jamais j'ai cette position là de [__]
ça
tu auras vite
ça veut dire plutôt non
pas plus
évidente d'ouvrir le centre
je pense que tu vois pour pouvoir garder
l'égalité mon pas plus
ouais donc attends dame c'est 7 vous
pensez-6 baisser B4 à 5 à 3 Fougères
[Musique]
pas sûr
n'empêche pas
oui le problème c'est le cœur sur A5
moi je pensais que tu veux aller pour
que le sang que je quitte
c'est vrai que c'est un peu double
[Musique]
largement mais
ok il est possible que tu es un peu
mieux ici même si est-ce que ici je
bosse sur B2
tu es obligé de prendre
c'est ça
je pense que je suis tout à fait ok
normalement
quoi
il est possible que tu es un peu mieux
j'avoue c'est je suis facile de pour
avouer quelque chose
moi il te faudrait être très précis mais
le plan doit être je sais pas essayer de
m'être la dame sur F4
défendre sur trois et puis pour ce âge
si tu réussis le plan général oui il a
fait H6
ok je vous ai prévenu dans ce 7 pour ce
mec c'est bien trop fort c'est pas n'est
pas
mais attends maintenant du coup si je
fais disons cavaliers
et tu vois si l'ordi il propose A6 aussi
moi je ferai juste vous prendre non et
ça ça si tu veux pas faire
on est d'accord là je pense c'est bien
ok cavalue 7 j'imagine
maintenant c'est à 5 l'autre coup mais
A5 non non
ça va jamais arriver déjà on comprend ah
ok l'idée c'est que il y a pas de souci
c'est déjà avantage blanc
c'est déjà une menace
quoi c'était trop en fait
marche à merveille il suffit juste de
sortir le mec de son cahier ça y est ça
part en couille mais complètement
pu faire un coup comme H600 parties mais
c'est pas précis moi je pense que c'est
un coup qui est digne d'être
sinon on va dire
je suis content que je vous ai appris à
mon russe très très très très utilisé
par les joueurs de chez glaire je pense
que c'est un mot plus souvent que les
échecs
parmi les joueurs de chaque
[Musique]
d'ailleurs quand va aller au 5 je veux
jouer tempo
oui mon chéri
et j'ai tout E2 libérateur
si tu fais KFC 5b4 A4 regardez donc les
candidats
les candidats 2008 ou presque
pas ils savent pas jouer là ils savent
pas jouer à gros je vous sortir du
contexte
on va voir on va voir mais ça peut ça
peut être très inquiétant pour Yann mais
ce que je comprends pas du coup c'est
s'il a du mal avec Carlsbad pourquoi il
a choisi ça contre Londres parce que
t'es pas du tout obligé en fait
parce que il comprend pas et que les
voiles contre 15 secondes est-ce que tu
as plein d'options contre Londres
d'ailleurs moi les parents que j'aime
bien jouer mais j'ai demandé à Baki m'a
dit c'est pas forcément bien mais moi
j'aime bien envoyer le fou en G4 et
juste buter le cavalier quoi écoute ok
je ce que je peux dire ok sur la théorie
générale tant que l'autoroute réfléchit
donc racontons un peu l'histoire faut
que ces trois E6 maintenant s'il te
plaît Kevin s'il te plaît refait le
premier coup cette position elle peut
arriver de les manières différentes le 4
c'est 6
b425 est décédé il faut deux trois que
les C6 c'est 3 que le F6 fulf 4
dans 3 dame de 7 que vous voulez de 2
E60 va voir la suite donc
retournons sur Londres
comme on en a obtenu ça donc comme tu as
dit avec non non
6 dans 23 dame de Sète vous serez non ok
dams
5 faut que je suis plutôt au milieu ici
les bons sont au milieu ici alors si
vous voulez jouer avec vous je 4 il est
plus intéressant de ne pas se changer
sur haut de 4 de ne pas donner trop de
liberté au blanc ça veut dire qui évolue
4 tout de suite
faut que je cadre tout de suite ces
trois E6 et là c'est l'une de murling
ouais
vous gardez les possibilités après 10
ans dans 23 dans 8 de jouer plus tard
ces quatre
[Musique]
H3
G4 faut juste 4 C4
ça y est ça commence mais c'est cool
pour le noir c'est juste une grosse
partie quoi
les bois en poussent là-bas les Noirs
poussent les Françaises
etc et grosse partie
là c'est pénible parce que le fou F5 il
peut se retrouver vraiment inutile
regarde les deux rouges
si l'oreille rougit c'est que ça va pas
pour lui je sais pas par rapport à
l'oreille je vois pas son oreille il me
voit que sa gueule est un logique comme
est-ce qu'on peut dire que sa gueule est
sinistre
depuis tout à l'heure oui mais qu'est-ce
que tu veux c'est un prix à payer quand
tu es capable de jouer à justice comme
ça c'est un prix à payer les blancs
visent la case E5 d'un 16 structures tu
laisses pas au blanc d'y mettre le
cavalier facilement alors tu fais gaffe
petit et tu joues pas HS
toi
il faut que je parle à tes parents
tu parles de Yann bah oui quoi
c'est étonnant c'est étonnant
ce match parce que tu as l'impression
que les joueurs jouent vraiment les
pièces et qu'ils ont tous les deux des
trous béants quoi
[Rires]
ça joue contre le style
avoir un article en fait ils disent que
tout tous les scientistes sont devenus
avec conclusion que l'histoire de Big
Ben et complètement nul non les trous
noirs de toute évidence ont existé avant
le Big Ben
et on en a bien deux en face de nous
parlant de trou noir mais tu sais ça me
fait penser
tu sais à quoi ça me fait penser ce
match un match de tennis entre un mec
qui a un mauvais coup droit contre un
autre qu'un mauvais revers
moi je pense que oui
c'est un match d'un avion que le contrat
et peut-être c'est politiquement pas que
ce que je dis moi
avec les trous noirs primordiaux non au
contraire ça confirme
mais c'est marrant que
Carlsen il est pas réussi à plus
exploiter en début de match
trop rouge
[Rires]
il est pas exploité cette faiblesse de
Yann parce qu'il joue tellement bien oui
mais tu as tellement volonté de je pars
attraper le durcir dans le futur le
problème n'oublie pas avant le match il
avait un score
[Musique]
mal contre n'importe dans les parties
classiques il avait peur de juste jouer
il a voulu enfin rester sur l'ouverture
éternel d'un joueur de chèque de gagner
à la maison
donc c'est un rêve éternel qu'est-ce que
tu veux
parce que là c'est vrai que connaissant
le niveau de Magnus dans la structure
carsbad et en voyant le début de cette
partie tu dis que
si l'entame trois parties comme ça c'est
3-0 en fait
non mais c'est tu donnes je pense que là
c'est Magnus avec les Blancs contre nepo
on peut partir
je me rappelle je me rappelle une fois
dans le Championnat du Monde rapide
a obtenu l'une des positions rêves à
Londres contre kamiko
je veux pas préciser parce que ok je me
rappelle pas de position de rêve et
c'était marrant je sais pour le reste de
la partie il est dépensé quelque chose
comme une minute ou deux et les jouets
déjà comme ça et il est juste tout citer
parce que rien que moi j'ai vu je l'ai
vu gagner de tel type de position
peut-être 5 fois et je pense que encore
sur l'Internet etc etc les maisons
machin peut-être gagner des Millions
regardez si ça vous intéresse
Championnat du Monde rapide à Moscou
système Londres regardez à partir d'un
moment donné les récitation trop facile
[Musique]
à 50% déjà 60
il est pas Magnus donc je vous donne
alors
entre 25 et 30 il est pas Magnus quand
même
déjà 60-70
parce que hier quand même j'ai perdu une
certaine partie de confiance il a
peut-être trouvé le meilleur coup
là il faut dire bravo comme je dis mille
fois pendant ce match c'est typique il y
a oui à la vitesse cosmique il faut une
connerie mais
pourquoi les remarquable il se refait
vite fait ouais c'est incroyable ouais
et comme ça toute sa vie en fait si vous
voulez il a pas trop de remorque le
décalé une autre fois il se dit bah ok
la vie est-elle pour une autre fois je
déconnais ok je joue pratique
il connaît les chemins et le chemin ici
c'est très souvent à 4 à 5 ouais très
très souvent
c'est l'une des règles en fait qui a
cassé d'ailleurs les règles d'eau avant
n'aurait jamais fait ça oui avant elle
disait
sur l'île de dames du roi ou votre
joueur est comme quoi destiné de jouer
vous vous
et en tant que pas d'activité mais
maintenant en fait cette règle n'existe
pas pourquoi est-ce que c'est les noirs
qui d'habitude sur l'île de dames les
raisons seul presque c'est parce qu'ils
ont une colonne où se met ouverte sur
l'île de dames tandis que les Blancs
d'habitude
font quelque chose sur l'île du roi
parce que donc les colonnes eux se met
ouverte est au blanc ce truc des
structures centrales quand elles point
d'un côté c'est plus facile de jouer
c'est assez bizarre mais tu fais
attention tu remarqueras que c'est
souvent le cas j'ai lu dans un livre
quand tu as une structure centrale du
côté vers lequel elle va plus facile de
jouer
d'accord j'ai juste ça dans un livre et
tu remarqueras que c'est hyper souvent
le cas
pas tout le temps mais c'est souvent le
cas
maintenant alors
si jamais à 6 ma chambre et voit
actuellement fou de trois fautes de
trois coller de droite de toute manière
c'est un certain aventage mais avant tu
es plutôt fouet je pense c'est plutôt de
toute manière c'est plutôt fou avec
l'idée A5
pardon s'il est bon arrivent à obtenir
ça ce que c'est un grand avantage
c'est déjà
plus que plus ça c'est déjà plus que
plus ça c'est vraiment dur à défendre
enfin plus un mot je pense que plus que
plus
ça il faut prendre en compte par contre
par contre les douanes si les bandes
arrivent à jouer oh mais si généralement
tu veux pas faire enfin moi je dirais
moi tu veux pas faire à moins qu'ils
veulent me rendre compte
parce que fou F1 tu es déjà je pense
qu'il veut jouer
elle est très sensible en plus le
cavalier il est à deux cases en
diagonale donc il est plus le plus
important c'est que dans plein de
scénario F5 vide vise le vide attends
l'ordi propose Fouin et A5 mais ok je
reviens
j'ai déjà entamé
en fait je suis pas sûr que quand
[Musique]
je vais revenir là-bas
où il y a plus non en fait tu as le seum
que j'ai proposé cavalier
le SAM t'es dégoûté que j'ai eu cavalier
bien cavalière
j'aurais opté peut-être pour football 5
et puis voir
parce que il y a pas de collier de 7 mec
peut-être tu veux pas trop jouer
à leur collège justice dans ce site
après que le sang
moi mon idée ça a été Kiev vous que vous
voulez
[Musique]
en fait cette histoire de Sam ça vient
de la victoire de la France contre la
Belgique en demi-finale de la Coupe du
monde parce que le gardien de l'équipe
belge a dit après le match on a dominé
on a eu la possession on a dominé et du
coup de de là ça vient un petit peu
l'histoire de dire que tu as le seum
quoi et il se plaît
et qui peut être traduit comment
exactement
combien de pour cent tu donc je joue à 5
moi je donne 50
parce que sinon sinon à 5h
que moi sans que tu fais pour éviter ça
il veut dire qu'on arrive ça veut dire
venin direct mais c'est quand tu es
dégoûté pour t'expliquer ça vraiment
comment dire comment dire merci en arabe
merci merci
je me suis dit peut-être
on peut faire une pause
j'ai déjà perdu
je peux dire un truc j'ai déjà perdu pas
mal de parties en beats comme ça et même
moi je veux plus jamais répéter ce truc
avec les Noirs
c'est horrible ça ok mes chers amis la
dernière question d'avoir la pause
qu'est-ce qu'on dit quand votre
adversaire joue ici ce que vous allez de
suite elle dit choucroute
merci
je te jure non mais notre rôle no enfin
pas de blague vraiment premier degré je
peux faire ça en blitz mais je suis
dégoûté de moi
[Musique]
et vous pouvez vérifier vous pouvez
reprendre mes Live vous pouvez faire
tout ce que vous voulez vous savez que
j'ai déjà eu ce genre de truc et je suis
écœuré
de gaieté de cœur je le ferai pas quoi
et cette fois-ci je suis pas dégoûté du
tout je suis très content parce que ce
sont les coûts qui ont été fait par le
premier chi donc ça prononce un petit un
bon avantage au brand on va voir le
reste ah mais je te jure que c'est mais
je te jure que ça m'a Lucie c'est le la
partie qui m'a lucide le plus là de
toute
parce que quand même enchaîner h6a6
cavalier E7 pour cavalier 17 non mais ce
que je comprends pas c'est si tu veux
faire après A4
enfin juste je comprends pas en fait à 6
kg le truc c'est que comme on va dire le
mec il est un peu prenant il doit
absolument faire quelque chose c'est ça
le problème mais par contre moi déjà un
peu dire mais quel choix génial de
l'ouverture par digne d'aujourd'hui mais
qu'elle soit j'ai soit génial
génialissime tu peux jamais obtenir
ou que ce soit
un tel avantage de maintenant non mais
ça c'est incroyable
cavalier E7 à 6 cavaliers de 17 tu
imagines qu'il
il a réfléchi [__] de 25 minutes pour
faire ça
non mais vlades
cinq jours et de toute manière tu vois
faire
à Bruxelles
que tu peux jouer des coups même pire
que ça mais
ça justement
[Musique]
c'est pas évident de trouver des cours
qui sont pires que de ne pas faire les
coups non mais oui même juste tu passes
en fait
d'ailleurs il faut donner l'option aux
échecs d'ailleurs ça va franchement
enrichir le jour
d'ailleurs une option fantastique
se laisser prendre ça ok au moins tu y
arrives avec le cavalier en D7 pour
tenir les cases mec le cavalier il faut
avoir une autre éruption après les amis
donc mes pots après les potes qui l'a
dit [__] il faut que je vois quoi
c'est de la merde il faut que je fasse
quoi
non mais là je suis choqué c'est je
pense que c'est le truc qui me qui m'a
le plus choqué de tout le match toutes
les autres erreurs je les ai compris et
elles sont normales mais là ça ça m'a
choqué
mais c'est peut-être parce que je joue
ça avec les noirs avec les Blancs que ça
me choque
c'est tout simplement parce que Kevin
toi tu fais pas c'est bien ton boulot de
missionnaire
éducatifs
jamais entamé une série de vidéos pour
les quinté tu penses qu'il faut qu'on
entame une série de vidéos pour les
candidats oui une série de vidéos pour
les candidats hey
comment il s'appelle
première épisode deuxième troisième
quatrième avec une voix une voix douce
d'oiseaux
[Rires]
[Musique]
sur ta chaîne tu vois
donation 5000 pour un court
tu vois
et puis c'est pas
toi
tu sais avec le pion vert en passant non
non
les couleurs rouges sur ce 5 et pas que
la case salarié
[Rires]
on en parle quoi
oui bah il a bouffé il va faire à 5
il faut quand même rajouter Yves black
[Rires]
tu penses qu'il faut le souligner ou pas
ouais
il a vu cette position et cette rupture
sans les cavaliers
[Rires]
a perdu hier à cause du Fou ce sang qui
faisait rien et l'autre
non mais par contre la même position
avec le cavalier en 17 ce serait moins
clair
oh non pas bien sûr mais il est sur eux
c'est juste pour le chat
bon c'est pas sûr qu'il va gagner mais
je donne bien du 50%
bien sûr une fois il a joué à leur
assise que vous voulez de cette en
permanent permettant à 5h etc bien sûr
devant 5 les chances de Jean sont
beaucoup augmenté donc maintenant je
considère ça change de gagner ça entre
alors 45 et 50
90 tu imagines la discussion de Ding ce
soir avec avec rapport comme il rejoue
avec les Blancs
radine qui dit a rapport il faut une
nouvelle idée avec les Blancs rapporte
répond bah juste tu rejoues Londres
pareil Elodie oui mais il faut avoir
travaillé avec podekine et rapport c'est
bon mais qu'est-ce que ça change
de toute façon il va avoir accès 7 et
alors quoi juste tu fais
H3
[Rires]
cette position quoi
et tu joues Ding merci c'est énorme
c'est incroyable comment
c'est fou les échecs comme on a tous des
points faibles et même à ce niveau-là
encore ils ont des faiblesses c'est
incroyable
c'est incroyable non mais ok
[Musique]
le problème c'est que quand tu changes
complètement tondre pour toi oui tu vas
pas tout doucement pour pouvoir tout de
suite comprendre
enfin tu vois qu'en être les terroristes
tu travailles grave et tout mais le
problème c'est que de toute manière les
comme je dis toujours les arbres
positionner ça va prendre du temps avant
de se lire il faut que tu
perd quelques parties
il faut que tu souffres dans quelques
parties vos meilleurs les parties jouer
chez toi donc sinon autrement c'est trop
dur tout simplement parce que vous savez
en fait que
il y a beaucoup de joueurs qui regardent
même pas du tout les parties pas de leur
répertoire
qui regardent les portiers les parties
jouer dans l'autre ouverture de les
autres virtuels mais comme ça juste en
cliquant
en cliquant tu vois jamais comprendre
quoi que ce soit en cliquant tu vois pas
jouer dans ce 7 comme il faut jouer mais
tu vas jouer à 6 comme il faut pas jouer
ouais mais c'est dur évidemment c'est
très dur mais
et sinon toi toujours
le seul truc que je trouve triste là
dedans c'est que il y a un vainqueur de
ce match il s'appelle bien Magnus
Carlson quand tu vois elle est partie
malheureusement
je pensais que tu vois dire que les
seules choses tu regrettes dans ce match
que il y aura pas de perdants quoi non
mais tu as l'impression que le grand
gagnant du match c'est Magnus en fait
parce que quand tu vois cette partie là
ok c'est juste l'universalité de Magnus
elle est incroyable quand tu compares
avec eux avec les autres tu dis ok
Magnus il est encore deux divisions
au-dessus mais
vous êtes peut-être un choqué comment on
en a rigolé tout à l'heure mais je pense
qu'il y avait quelqu'un au monde qui a
rigolé beaucoup plus gravement en voyant
H6 à 6 quand elle est de 7 etc il y a il
y a il y avait quelqu'un
mais ce qu'on veut dire que n'est pas en
dehors
c'est pas une compréhension
superficielle c'est pas du tout ça qu'on
veut dire c'est qu'en fait il est pas
universel c'est comme si tu étais un
joueur de tennis et tu étais bon sur les
coups droits les revers les machins mais
à un moment donné je sais pas sur les
bas liftés en coup droit dans l'angle en
fait tu as du mal à répondre et en fait
c'est bien ça c'est qu'il y a un enfin
pour faire une métaphore tennistique
c'est qu'il y a un type de balle à un
endroit où tu as du mal à répondre et
juste si on devise dessus bah on va
gagner le match quoi question de réponse
pourquoi si c'était pas bon alors si
c'était pas bon parce que ça a permis
aux brins de mettre le coller sur E5
mais peut-être mission n'était pas là
tandis que danse cette profil active
aurait pu permettre au noir de répondre
sur corolleo 5 on les prend E5 et 2
c'est plus une fourchette c'est basique
c'est basique si le type joue ça pour
les premières fois bien sûr il le sent
pas voilà c'est quand même ce serait
fait prendre pareil bah ils sont les
deux sont plus fort quand même VL en
tout cas en ce moment donc oui c'est
leur niveau est incroyable c'est juste
que il souffre énormément la comparaison
par rapport à Magnus mais
tu sais quand je vois ça je comprends
pourquoi Hikaru est tellement monté
dernièrement
parce que je pense qu'il Caro en fait il
est
bien par rapport à eux
ok il est pas nettement moins fort
ma caméra c'est trop
bien
large donc de tel truc bien sûr non bien
sûr c'est pour ça que je te dis qu'en
réalité quand tu voyais ko qui finit 3e
ou 4e des candidats mais qui était à
deux doigts de la deuxième place quand
tu vois le match tu dis ok est-ce que
Hikaru il aurait pas sa place ici
non mais en plus les gens il y a
d'autres problèmes moi je veux dire je
veux dire c'est pas normal quand même
c'est pas normal quand même que moi
avoir un entamé sa carrière de streamer
machin ça fait 10 ans peut-être que joue
12 Virtuos sur quatre
enfants
ok ils sont capables de ce qu'on voit
maintenant mais ce sont de travailleurs
quoi
c'est stream stream stream
comment s'appelle
il y a quelque chose qu'il est temps
donc faut aller au beau petit boulot de
encore comment dire faire un petit stop
sur Berlin pour
[Musique]
c'est pas à cause de ça que je l'appelle
little finger depuis un moment je pense
pas que tu l'as points
[Musique]
était comme toujours depuis longtemps
pas depuis toujours d'ailleurs depuis
longtemps
ouais non mais ça peut pas être mis sur
le compte du stress ou quoi ces erreurs
là c'est vraiment de la compréhension
pure en fait c'est juste
donner une pièce en un ou faire une
gaffe ou ce genre de choses mais là
c'est trop
toutes les vies vous êtes un joueur de
des ouvertures fermées avec les bons et
là d'un coup d'une manière ou l'autre
bizarrement vous vous retrouverez
à l'attaque anglaise
dommage d'Orfeuille avec je connais la
suite d'ailleurs la partie de la plus
ridicule dans l'attaquant Grèce du côté
de blanc c'était la partie carpe
avec les noirs et puis il devait
absolument égaliser et donc d'un coup il
a eu cette idée de
d'entendre
mon conseil regardez cette partie c'est
drôle l'attaquant
mais après faut être précis sur moi avec
les Blancs quand même ici
je peux me tromper peut-être mais c'est
ce que maman veut faire ok l'ordi veut
cavaler ici ah oui oui
excusez-moi j'ai vu ça oui bien sûr donc
alors
c'est 5 non
ou dans ma classe
mais il est vrai que pour l'instant je
me lance pas parce que moi j'aime bien
ces trucs genre dame F3 tours 3 B4 un
passé comme ça il est possible que
auprès de me retrouver
c'est pour ça qu'on en parlait tout à
l'heure le cavalier sur la va sur la
case des 7 normalement mais quand bien
même c'est très long
non le problème c'est que si le cavalier
arrive sur 17 et les bandes arrivent
avant de se lèvres
[Musique]
peut-être va pas trouver des après parce
que
sur la colonne et ça va être un problème
donc
la manoeuvre est bonne mais déjà il est
long c'est quand même trois coups
et à la fin du compte de ce que vous
savez d'ailleurs exactement le même
nombre de coups les bons ont besoin pour
mettre le Corolla sur ce sang
[Musique]
excuse-moi non ça va être ça va être
avantage long terme là
mais dans mes front puisque bien c'est
que tu retardes vraiment les E5 tout
contre je
ce que tu tapes et tu tapes non ouais
je pense
si tu réussis à pousser E5 de l'écho à
venir ça va pas trop t'aider non non je
sais mais bon tu bloques encore une
option plus d'habitude
une seule faiblesse donc S5 puis on
isolé mais ça va être renforcé par le
fruit que les noirs ont des pions
sur les cases blanches sur l'aile de
dame aussi donc si vous voulez avec A6
quand elle est foutu à 6 ce type l'un
des problèmes c'était que il a affaibli
les CACES 5 avis et l'autre problème
c'est que pour les finales
éventuellement de fou enchanté
un gros avantage mais je comprends pas
même un coup comme H3 j'aurai
l'impression que je suis nettement mieux
franchement c'est vraiment pas un bon
coup
ça dépend c'est qu'est-ce qui en appel à
grande avantage
dans tous les cas par rapport au
standard de cette ouverture
parce que cette virtuose bébé
Game of Thrones le mec adorable
très bien joué
[Musique]
parce que pour de tels trucs
il faut il faut punir il faut punir à
vie
on est d'accord qu'on vient d'expliquer
pourquoi c'est bien joué
d'être désagréable le deuxième chose moi
en évidant que le premier
tour c'est lui ou l'autre
et sur cavalier C8 cavalier D6 ouais
mais tu vas où en fait
cavalier
se sent que
j'ai eu peur
ok apprendre j'ai eu un peu peur les
rappeurs vont comprendre apprendre le
covelet sur ce 5
les rappeurs vont comprendre
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
mais ouais non mais
non mais 60% de victoire déjà
non non
pas plus tu es sûr
il est sensible il est un peu hystérique
et il joue très bien elle ajoute
vraiment c'est comme ça donc aucune
confiance en Lui c'est pas du tout une
machine
donc il est capable de glisser Magnus 90
Magnum
80 90 enfin on compte ne pose sur un
compte n'est pas peut-être même 95
parce que en fait
le pire problème de Magnus counter pour
avant leur match ça a été qui ont
souvent
il y a la dribbler dans les
complications et ce que le taux avec un
tel cavalier comme souris sur C5 après
B4 c'est qu'il y a plus il y a plus de
complications un peu plus
rien
ça y est il existe que l'opium c'est
trois amer d'accord écoutez il attaque
mon pion je sais pas trop vous savez
fière massage
ok il est vrai tu montes je me défends
pas de problème c'est quoi ton prochain
coup quoi ça va pas durer longtemps pour
ces 6
[Rires]
power c'est quoi ton prochain
et tu rigoles
c'est dommage que les joueurs puissent
pas s'écrire des petits messages de
temps en temps
[Musique]
après le type le type joue quelque chose
qu'on précise
c'est quoi les réactions correctes
d'après toi
moi je pense que je suis venu à une
conclusion
pour voir pousser à 100 que je vais
faire P4 c'est sûr je pense Beckett
et 3
ça me permet de vous raconter qui ont
mon entraîneur en Kazakhstan il a été un
très bon hier ami
il a joué contre le champion du monde y
compris le jeu contre muslov et il m'a
dit que la plus grosse impression que il
a eu parmi les champions du monde contre
qui le joueur il est dit c'était quoi
le sentiment il a dit c'était carrément
les sentiments de je sais pas comment
s'appelle ce truc là quatre pires où
j'ai pas
fini qui qui marche sur toi que roulent
que sur toi enfin
comment s'appelle cette machine qui fait
la sfold
[Musique]
tu comprends tu essaie de stopper et non
il y arrive de toute manière contre lui
ça arrive si il est décédé que c'est le
point que le colis voyait arriver quoi
et là ce que marrant c'est que tu
ressembles dernière tentative
non ça va y arriver attends mais
j'espère si le type a trouvé dame of
Thrones
c'est vraiment facile mais comme tu dis
ce qui me fait peur c'est qu'il peut
être un peu hystérique il est stérile et
historique
pire que de les films X
ça fait peur
peut-être n'est pas lâché l'affaire non
t'inquiète il va défendre frérot
c'est quoi l'idée de tour à deux bah
dans certaines ventes se défendre B2
mais c'était dans d'autres variantes il
y a bien longtemps mais faut suivre en
fait quand on parle
[Rires]
le chinois
en plus
c'est possible aussi non mais je disais
juste c'est que le fait non mais
j'aurais pas fait parce que quand tu
fais cavalier B3 tu protèges plus le
pion donc c'est un peu zarbi
les tours E3 peut-être possible aussi
mais j'aurais préféré torcer un bah si
pour l'instant il faut il faut
un B4 kb3 cavalier C5 et après tu
reviens en haut
dire cure comme ça la tour contrôler la
case E5 il y a de bonnes raisons pour
ces choses qui ont la main veut oui oui
la tour elle est bien trop exposée
non mais tu viens là tu fais ça sur
reviens là
façon tu as le temps quand vous aurez
réussi à mettre votre cavalier en C5 en
fait les Noirs ils vont passer leur tour
ils ont plus de coup en fait c'est fini
c'est vous avez les mains en fait une
fois le cavalier sur ce 5 vous allez le
temps de sortir de la salle du jour de
vous acheter une cigare bons cigarette
je recommande donc prendre un bon café
j'ai pas passé une demi-heure à
l'extérieur parce que
c'est peinard c'est peinard il y a pas
de problème pro dans votre vie jusqu'à
la fin de cette partie oui
tu peux même troll quand tu as le
cavalier en 5 tu fais cavalier à 4 tu
menaces cavalier B6 il se barre tu
reviens
[Rires]
au fait je reviens et vous savez il y a
de saletés est-ce qu'ils font c'est une
fois il joue BK
[Musique]
il commence à enlever la poussière sur
la case et il y a des salty tu sais ce
qu'ils font il reste assis il se lève
plus il reste assis il contemple ta
gueule pendant que tu réfléchis ça c'est
horrible ça m'est déjà arrivé juste il
fait ça il enlève un peu la casser 5 et
il te contemple quoi
non mais si
c'est assez terrible
tous les jeunes de sale type en fait je
me rappelle que à un moment donné je me
suis senti vraiment pas trop bien et je
veux même dire pour quelle raison j'ai
eu une nuit assez
mouvementé mouvement de théorie je me
sens mal par contre je dois gagner
d'ailleurs je dois être je dois gagner
pour jouer pour équipe par équipe je
l'ai bon et Dieu et donc il est nomade
il a compris que je me sens mal il me
manque pour moi
donc je commençais de réfléchir comme ça
tu sais ce qui le commence à faire
il m'a regardé
la table dans la gueule
il est plus fort que moi physiquement et
tu vois c'est tout ça le problème sinon
tu aurais fait ouais
non tous les genres de celle-ci il était
et aux échecs tu l'as battu quand même
ou pas il était complètement nul
c'est un bon grammaire d'ailleurs mais
ce jeu très vite j'ai obtenu un gros
avantage bah sinon je répare un contexte
ce soir
je suppose
et surtout c'est un E5 ouais mais bon ok
juste on va prendre et on va jouer ce
pion isolé d'ailleurs
même ça c'est très agréable
mais techniquement ça marche pas
non peut-être par contre il peut
peut-être essayer de tourser un fois 7
B4
oui
une grosse question pour moi si par
exemple je prends pas sur E5 et je joue
jusqu'à
4 et F5 c'était le mois 1900 et je dois
pas le permettre d'ailleurs grosse
question si je joue les finales même
dame je crois que vous voulez se sent
que après peut-être je joue pour le
pousser poussin très possible que même
avantage mais je l'ai flemme de
réfléchir profondément non mais ça ça
peut être une idée pour les Noirs oui
oui
c'était des il faut faire quelque chose
donc de peut-être
jouer pour un petit peu plus tôt OK et
si on prend mais que le droit alors
qu'est-ce que ça donne
bah ça donne un bon avantage de toute
manière
la plus cool de toute façon le cavalier
il va arriver sur cette [__] de casser
5 ouais tu vas toujours pas l'empêcher
en fait
mais
clairement il vit mais
c'est les seuls les seules les seules
choses qui explique tout ce week-end il
veut à l'heure donc
provoquer les points de
jeux et puis oui ça va devenir possible
alors
en couple plus tard si le noir joue à
force
bon je pense que peut-être c'est le
moment parfait pour la pause
avec
et après on revient ouais parce que là
ça va réfléchir à tout de suite les amis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon alors il s'est passé quelques petits
trucs depuis qu'on est parti il y a eu
deux coups donc surtout FC8 il a joué
tour à trois qui menace pas vraiment B4
cavalier B3 parce que comme on l'a dit
la tour
défendrait pas latéralement de pion
lorsque le cavalier arrive en B3 sur
quoi il y a juste fouger 6 qui est un
petit coup de préparation ça libère
notamment la case F5 pour le cavalier ça
replace le fou sur une meilleure case et
cavalier B3 quand même probablement
l'idée de tour à tronc on la comprend
maintenant c'est que sur cavalier C6 il
veut peut-être jouer tour à 1 ouais
mais peut-être il va commencer par dame
G3 d'ailleurs pour prendre un peu le
contrôle de la case 5
il y a deux façons de traiter ça essayer
de changer les dents ou pas moi j'ai
réessayé de ne pas échanger pour garder
cette possibilité pour plus tard et
peut-être pour des idées le sort de le
parti par l'attaque
il contrôle peut-être un peu trop
attention c'est pas des erreurs mais
c'est juste ça fait peur pour la suite
peut-être Kévin tu peux montrer l'une de
tour à 3 imaginons c'était pas faux G6
mai 6 là il y a un mais B6 par exemple
mais bon c'était même pas la peine
d'avoir
bon pour le spectateur
oui mais bon l'ordi propose tout ré 8
ici bon ok
il est pas aimé mais qui va faire
tourcer 8 tu auras trois tours 8 ou
pousser deux ok bon c'est vous êtes très
gentil mais personne va jouer tous ces
deux pour ton cerf où j'ai 6
c'est même pas imaginable sauf celui qui
perd autant mais donc comme ça elle peut
récupérer des secondes ou celui qui
vibre
bon donc on en est là après cavalier B3
bon il va y arriver comme promis alors
leur
idée ici
OK
je peux
tout doucement
de ce bruit
donc tour E1 avec les dettes
j'espère que ça marche
c'est un peu comment dire
c'est dangereux parfois ça marche est-ce
que tu as noté mon verbe échafauder
quand même
c'est peut-être la meilleure option pour
Yann de tenter de faire marcher ça moi
de toute manière on ne peut pas
permettre aux band de réussir que les C5
BK parce que c'est bien trop il faut
faire quelque chose qui me fait kiffer
quand même dans la partie c'est quand tu
réfléchis ça lui a pas du tout posé de
problème de laisser faire
un certain moment et tout d'un coup
quand il fait tout pour l'empêcher
il a fait cavaler 6 ok les deux ah oui
ok il les ramène sur de cette alors il a
pas donné il empêche si
tiens tiens tiens
ouh là
c'est beau ça c'est beau c'est beau ça
prend des quatre et
tours
ouais donc comme d'habitude
d'amener à la partie feu moyen un bon
café j'ai une autre leçon à te donner
mais cette finale tu la gagne ou pas il
a fait dame
tu la gagne
ok
j'ai des bonnes choses quand même mais
je pense tu as l'intérêt quand même de
me stopper sur l'île du roi
j'ai recommencé avec H5
en tout cas il a pas fait oui il faut
stopper les structures enfin il faut
bloquer les structure H5 parce que F3 G4
ça peut être bien trop mesdames 7 c'est
bizarre
j'allais pas mon message à la rigueur on
s'en fiche mais ça met la dame juste en
face de la Tour ça veut dire que il peut
y avoir des problèmes sur des 5
maintenant à certains moments
globalement E5 c'est plus du tout au
menu puisqu'il y aura toujours pu on
prend et F4 quasiment
comme d'habitude c'est trop donc en fait
il fait tout pour empêcher le cavalier
C5 c'est marrant
donc je suppose surtout
pas
ok ok
pourquoi est-ce que c'est possible
maintenant non mais je veux juste savoir
parce que quand la tour est en 3 il y a
cavalier C4 qui touche mais attends et
si je fais tout Français 4
je comprends pas pourquoi je peux pas le
faire en fait
cavalier prendre la tour protégée
menacée
ok mais c'est tropable
c'est logique en fait
oui
non
l'idée que une fois la dame sur je
trouve les dettes des cavaliers
non mais toi en plus enfin la tour
maintenant elle a rempli son rôle elle
est elle a plus rien à faire elle est
bien placée en a ce qui est bien ce qui
après tour à 1 et le cavalier va arriver
sur ce 5 est-ce que bien c'est que ça
rend ni pour me chie complètement comme
un clown quoi et il a tout fait pour
éviter ce 5 mais en 20 tu sais ce qui
est bien c'est que il aurait été mieux
en place il avait juste checké
parce qu'en plus regarde il a foutu la
tour eiffe sur C8 la dame sur recettes
et peut-être qu'il était juste mieux
avec la dame en C7 et la tour en fuite
en fait peut-être tu aurais dû dire
de ne pas jouer cette partie de ne pas
jouer ce match de ne pas apparaître
clown quoi
c'est pas sûr quand même que dingy fasse
il a montré par le passé qu'il était
capable de déconner
il a été quand même un bon jeu
ouais mais la pression le stress
marrant ce match
F4 c'est dangereux parce que faut E4 que
va les bouge F5 arrive et là ça va les
bons vont crier un super cavalier sur ce
5 mais les Noirs vont créer un super fou
sur E4 donc
ça tu dois pas laisser ça c'est un
problème
la stratégie c'est l'art de
prendre sans rien donner maîtriser les
pions maîtriser les pions donc les pions
nos échecs c'est parce qu'ils tombent
dans un corps humain et donc faut faire
gaffe à ça
quel autre manière de faire c'est tout
droit si l'idée c'est de protéger la
tour
ça c'est vrai que c'est pas évident de
trouver un mot pour moi tout AAA et plus
facile de trouver que tu retrouves en
fait parce que à vrai dire ça a été
toujours ma faiblesse aux échecs
d'ailleurs pour moi c'était dur de
maîtriser les pièces quand elles sont un
peu
à gauche
alors elle servait tout à l'heure
maintenant elle sert plus
elle a servi pour protéger un peu ces
trois et pour permettre de ramener la
tour en
c'est en fait c'est typiquement aux
échec c'est que
il y a beaucoup le coup vous a bien
servi moi il faut pas comment dire il
faut pas se tenir à ce que vous a servi
il y a quelques temps donc il faut
abandonner ce que votre surveiller vous
a servi avant donc pour de nouveaux
aventures oui voilà
c'est d'ailleurs quand tu donnes des
cours à des joueurs amateurs c'est un
des trucs les plus difficiles à acquérir
aux échecs c'est de remettre à jour
les plans et les idées après chaque coup
voilà c'est hyper dur pour les joueurs
amateurs hyper dur quand tu as commencé
adulte c'est vraiment dur ça
oui
sauf si vos adversaire joue vraiment à
trop trop mal en fait on peut pas gagner
une partie juste en améliorant en
améliorant en améliorant pas par pas en
fait c'est pas comme ça en fait vous
améliérez votre position mais parfois
vous devez faire les pas en arrière en
fait en améliorant toujours les
positions c'est un paradoxe mais
c'est un signe
mais je pense souvent il peut avoir
seconde style
parmi les deux coups que il a il va
choisir 3 ce son style parce que il est
large son style est large comme quoi
il peut
alors voir un coup jouet
une heure 4 minutes pour Ding contre une
heure 14 minutes pour ne pas de toute
manière je pense ne peut jamais être
donc peut-être c'est même pas les points
de regarder sur ce pendule par contre
les pendule de Digne
doit être survivre
ni réfléchit beaucoup
bon ouais il voit qu'il a une vraie
chance et donc il faut pas qu'il glisse
même si ok jusqu'à présent il a fait un
coup bizarre plus ou moins 3 tu ressens
a été beaucoup plus clean mais quand
même parce qu'il faut se cohérence
logique maintenant il suffit juste
[Musique]
comment s'appelle un dernier effort le
voir arriver sur ce sac et ça va être
une autre phase dans la partie mais où
tu as beaucoup moins de risques de faire
une bêtise avec les Blancs et comme le
cavalier va passer les frontières il y a
beaucoup plus de risques que nous
pouvons déconner oui beaucoup plus
va donc passer les frontières entre la
quatrième et le cinquième rangée
ce qu'on appelle aux échecs chinois les
rivières
le Rubicon
que et qui disent allez à chaque taille
n'est-ce pas
c'est intéressant d'ailleurs si tu es
éduqué de le manière chinoise mais à
bloc oui est-ce que tu connais de telle
expression parce que nous les canettes
tous bien sûr
très très comme quoi européenne
[Rires]
ils doivent connaître quand même est-ce
que oui
connaissance mais généralissime
généralissime de la couture européenne
[Musique]
nous qu'est-ce qu'on connaît de la
culture chinoise pas grand chose en fait
bah
le match quoi
mis sur la gueule il y a tout un tas de
noms dont je me rappelle plus mais on
connaît pas grand chose ok je connais la
guerre des royaumes il y en avait 7 déjà
ils étaient comme quoi rouler par les
matchs pendant trois siècles avant les
rivaux de communistes oui pendant trois
siècles donc si tu veux rouler par les
par les nomades moi du rien c'est les
nomades les manchots quoi enfin André ça
nous appelle-moi de rien quoi c'est les
nomades qui sont le plus à l'Est quoi le
plus à l'est donc sinon qu'est-ce que je
sais pas grand chose non plus en fait
enfin
se termine de comment s'appelle
que il y a genre 40 ans mais ils ont
trouvé toute une armée oui et chaque
figure a une gueule différente en fait
il y a déjà
1000 comment s'appelle
comment dire en France ça je sais pas
sinon pas grand chose même si ma copine
elle est réductrices du chinois
j'aimerais tellement aller en Chine tu
imagines pas c'est un de mes rêves quoi
mais il faut que tu choisis bien la
destination parce que c'est pas partout
c'est intéressant que ça en fait moi je
te propose je te recommande d'aller sur
les bords sur les villes au bord de mer
en tout cas j'ai envie de voir
ouais tu l'es plutôt interdit mais
qu'ils sont tes origines russes
ukrainienne
gitan
est assez inattendu et Anaïs
c'est-à-dire sauf si on fait pas gaffe à
mais tu as une ressemblance à créer
lyota qui est assez choquante ok
incroyable tous les gens à qui je l'ai
dit ils disent ouais tu vois [__] de
ouf ouais ouais c'est pour les gens qui
ont vu The Good fait la si tu ressembles
énormément à surtout quand tu rigoles tu
ressembles vraiment à elliotta dans la
scène mythique donc je ressemble
à celui qui voit trahir quoi c'est ça
non mais ça se passe bien
oui et non en fait oui et non c'est vrai
mais c'est pas si clair
mais d'ailleurs c'est beau la fin la
dernière phrase du film est
extraordinaire je me rappelle pas quand
tu dis enfin j'ai plus la citation
exacte mais j'étais un plouc j'étais
devenu un plouc un raté j'ai commandé
des
spaghettis à des pénis sauce à
matriciana et on m'a servi des
spaghettis au ketchup
mais j'adore en fait l'image ok pour un
Italien c'est trop spaghetti au ketchup
en fait à vrai dire je vote chez les
vérité je pense que
l'acteur aurait pu jouer mieux ce rôle
parce que je pense que même quand tu
connais pas ce qui va arriver c'est
écrit sur sa gueule que il va très bien
enfin tu vas pouvoir changer du camp le
camp
ouais ouais c'est écrit sur sa gueule
la performance de jeu dans ce film
incroyable mais bon Jovi est toujours
incroyable
et tu as une autre famille de mythique
de ce corps 16 dans ce film quand il
filme tout en avec une caméra qui suit
derrière non c'est
quand on apprend ce corps 16 dans les
écoles cinématographiques
ils apprennent les jambes à filmer comme
scorses ils disent que ce plan qui dure
une minute trente avec le gars la caméra
c'est pour montrer à quel point il
évolue facilement dans le milieu mafieux
donc le plan il coule comme ça pendant
plus d'une minute c'est pour montrer son
ascension facile et sans coupure sans
difficulté bah il a fait H4
pourquoi pas au final
ok il veut dire que il peut tout faire
en attendant
quoique je vois toujours pas de raison
pourquoi pas comment c'est tout de suite
mais bon
c'est fatiguant en fait non
je sais pas c'est doit être ça doit être
le sentiment des parents quand elle
suive je crois leur fils en train de
jouer au foot à tiens il est tombé
c'est comme ça que je suis mon cher Ding
dans ce match quand tu as commencé la
phrase
comme en russe vous avez du mal à bien
prononcer les uns et les 1 j'ai cru que
ça veut dire c'est comme pour un parrain
de suivre
et tu suis quoi
c'est pas parce que je tiens pour dire
mais dans tous les cas je tiens pour
concours
à comprendre c'est que si Ding gagne pas
aujourd'hui enfin si per le match est
terminé et s'il gagne pas aujourd'hui
quand même on va commencer en avoir des
doutes quoi ouais parce que
mais bon H4 c'est vrai que tu poses la
question au noir
pourquoi tu joues en fait
parce que si tu bouges le fou maintenant
pour éviter les cavaliers progressistes
dans des variantes il y aura H5
peut-être c'est ça qui va
pourquoi pas jouer à 5 si tu as joué à 4
d'ailleurs
non non non
mais pas encore mais
petite précision
je reviens un petit peu dans la partie
assez
cavalier des 7
pour se prendre à 5 ah d'accord
pourquoi pas je sens qu'ici du coup
150 après cavalier c'est 5
attends il faut il faut comprendre
l'idée que voler à 5 tours 5 B6 c'est
quoi les deux joueurs.com je suis Serge
je suis nul et je vois pas encore
comment on dit merci en chinois bah je
sais pas justement je sais pas il faut
que je demande ma copine oh
oh
[__] c'est 10 points en fait c'est
hyper dit
en fait il est trop fort pour qu'on
prenne ses coups oh oh et c'est
surprenant H4 c'était vraiment fort on
n'avait pas du tout vu
ouh là
ils disent tu dis chichi chien
[Musique]
[Rires]
en fait il porte encore mieux son nom
il peut gagner comme ça l'autre il peut
rater un tel truc où il peut rater ça
non un tel truc tu peux c'est facile ça
c'est extraordinaire en fait parce que
un petit coup à côté non en fait H4 on a
rigolé mais le coup est juste incroyable
j'ai tellement faim et profond comme
coup et tellement menteur est tellement
moderne et tellement alpha alpha zéro
ça c'est 3000 plus un tel coup de H4
pour cavalier C5 avec H5 et cavalier
c'est incroyable j'ai mangé une Carson a
prouvé le quoi je connais c'est
impressionnant comme quoi en fait
qu'est-ce que après tous les sons les
échecs modernes qu'est-ce que c'est les
échecs modernes c'est l'art de maîtriser
les H4 au bon moment et le jeu sur les
deux ailes aussi beaucoup plus qu'avant
encore ouais parce que ils aiment
maintenant dominer partout un peu comme
le GO ok justement l'influence du jeu de
Go l'influence du jeu de Go l'espace
l'espace l'espace
l'idée de il vient de juge je pense non
parce que il est fou un petit mouvement
il est un peu hystérique peut-être non
l'idée de H5 c'est que ça décale le fou
et maintenant qu'on te fait cavalier
prend aussi son menaces de cette mat
donc il a pas le temps de prendre et
quand il prend ici la dame est clouée
donc on a le temps de reprendre en
dessin avec la tour et on va être
complètement gagnant H5 strip-tease la
case chaussette
tu fais H4 pour attaquer la case G7 avec
la dame et le enfin c'est incroyable
comme coup magnifique
fantastique
incroyable oh là là quel type quoi
il va pas être bien vas-y vas-y
qu'est-ce qui vient de faire là
vous nous critiquez pour que les
critiques toujours oui ça c'est le
niveau d'un vrai candidat quoi
éventuellement même champion
c'est digne digne d'être
H4 pour faire un marché cavalier c'est 5
c'est le niveau est incroyable
stratosphérique
tu vois ça j'aurais jamais été capable
de trouver en partie impossible trop dur
moi aussi H4
le niveau de jeu là c'est incroyable ah
il doit pas être bien Rihanna oh oh
catastrophe catastrophe
[Rires]
d'ailleurs
combien sont nombreux ceux qui savent
comment se réduire le nombre de
vous êtes nombreux à connaître qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire en fait
à savoir tu peux dire mais
en russe celui qui se rappelle pas
bizarre comme nom d'ailleurs
je peux te raconter une anecdote assez
marrante que j'ai vu je crois que
c'était pendant les derniers candidats
yarajabov qui allait voir dingly Rennes
et qu'il a demandé mais ton nom ça se
prononce Ding li Rennes ou dinglygène
non j'entends pas la différence
[Rires]
ça prononciation est tellement pourri
j'entends pas la différence quoi
et c'est beau
je pense que les Japonais aussi ils
n'ont pas
[Musique]
ici les japonais ils n'ont pas herche je
pense
ça n'existe pas au Japon si je me trompe
pas mais vous vous avez un son qu'on a
pas assez U
u u
moi j'arrive pas à bien le dire
ça existe quelque chose il y a un film
comme ça opérat c'est
u c'est hyper dur à dire comme comme son
papa
bien sûr
j'ai du mal aussi avec eux
et pourtant parfois il faut le dire on
veut pas savoir quand
[Rires]
il suit n'est pas
c'est que quand elle est perdue ou la
partie précédente avec le noir oui il à
partir d'un moment donné il ne pouvait
plus bouger oui
à partir d'un moment donné digne pour
plus bouger oui ici c'est exactement les
mêmes situations pendant assez longtemps
il va pas pouvoir bouger en fait juste
et
il
y aura que attendre en fait
oui mais est-ce que ça va aider alors
le problème c'est que les noirs peuvent
espérer que sur F5 F4 un beau jour mais
ça va jamais arriver
c'est ça le problème de noix donc
d'ailleurs
l'ordinateur
donne ici comme un coup F3 moi je leur
ai jamais fait
moi je pense
[Musique]
plutôt à faire quelque chose sur l'île
dedans en fait
de toute manière une fois il a mis sa
dame sur E7 ça dort sur E8 l'idée même
de échanger le cavalier sur ce 5 donc
par Caballero
donc il y a plus de dés que pousser au
centre est mourir ou ne pas pousser le
sang et mourir donc
ça va être joué c'est sûr
ou pas
aussi ok la difficulté là pour Ding
c'est que il va falloir être précis et
c'est là que des joueurs du niveau de
Yann deviennent complètement imbattable
pour des joueurs ornent du top
ce que il y a un doit commencer
maintenant il doit plus rester sage en
fait
OK
certes il va gagner un pion
ça reste intéressant bien sûr
ou pas danser
mais c'est juste que ça fait peur parce
que c'était tellement c'est tellement
gagnant stratégiquement tu sais quoi ça
me ressemble
ça me ressemble
il a eu une pause gagnante
elle est très intéressante cette phrase
il a eu une position gagnante moi au
lieu de gagner
il s'est mis pour attaquer grave il faut
aller au calculer la fois le calcul et
tout il a gagné et dans ces commentaires
il est écrit
en ce moment-là
j'étais dans un tel état que j'ai pas pu
croire à ma mère si je joue toujours
positionné moi
[Musique]
en gros ce que veut dire Vlad c'est que
comme il était trop nerveux il a préféré
continuer à jouer tactique pour être
obligé de calculer
tranquillement c'était bien trop pour
son état donc je pense que ça explique
alors son choix qui sinon un peu bizarre
mais pourquoi pas d'ailleurs non mais
c'était bien joué c'est juste c'est
étonnant mais c'est peut-être bien joué
mais ici il faut bien le calculer bien
sûr tu auras 3 quand le secret qui
viennent à considérer de mais peut-être
dans mon sang
je trouve que je dois parce que
juste F4
[Musique]
je suis en train de faire grossophobe va
devenir plus fort parce que un jour
peut-être il y aura l'occasion de venir
sur le cadre
je vais au bouffer avec la dame
maintenant
et maintenant
dans B6 que veut dire
et ici
danse de retour ce 8 il est vrai il y a
juste dans notre
salaire d'être bien joué mais ça par
contre c'est complètement gagnant ça ça
c'est complètement gagnant ça c'est fini
oui donc dans
quand même
ah c'est la pause oui c'est vrai ouais
ouais mais là ils vont enchaîner
l'écoute c'est forcé
quoi d'autre
il me fait peur quand même le fou fou
vous savez pour jouer un tour B3 vous
devez être vraiment sûr dans vos calculs
vraiment être sûr de soi surtout contre
quelqu'un tricky comme pour parce que si
après l'évolution est cohérente et là
vous allez choisir les points tandis que
ici tout se tient sur arme de couleur tu
sais par en revanche un truc que j'ai
remarqué les mecs Triki comme des pots
souvent les variantes hypertrichies
comme ça ils calculent pas par flemme en
espérant qu'ils intriquent oui bien sûr
c'est pas mal de rentrer dedans parce
qu'en fait ils ont pas regardé ils ont
juste parti ces tricks ici intrigue je
trouve s'il y a Patrick je perds et donc
si tu calcules au fond et que tu es sûr
en fait juste tu les balayes mais c'est
risqué
la plupart des positions foutues au
compteur Ding c'est comme ça qu'il ne
pourraient parce que l'autre veut le
battre au fond quoi
apparemment bah je sais pas c'est le
coup principal
en gros qu'est-ce que je veux dire pour
pouvoir battre pour pouvoir gagner dans
le match pour le titre
le plus souvent vous devez renaître vous
devez pas suivre vos instincts de
toujours donc vous devez devenir Phoenix
quoi vous devez mourir et remettre pour
donc
venir au match différent parce que là
maintenant peut-être c'est très bien ce
qu'il faut être peut-être possible mais
il est il se répète au niveau des
instants
juste tu mets la position gagnante et en
fait tu attends de cueillir le fruit qui
mûrit oui parce qu'il va donner la
partie Yann tôt ou tard il va donner
quelque chose et donc tu as pas besoin
tu as pas besoin de rentrer dans un truc
aussi compliqué là-dessus je trouve que
tu as raison Magnus il aurait jamais
employé cette technique pour gagner
oui mais parce que tout va se jouer
maintenant sur un coup sur un doute
tandis que après
je suis grand favori concerné pour toi
tu es un grand favori concerné pour
spécifiquement comprenez pas oui
une fille qui se promène sur les
croisettes en train de tricher les
vitres lécher les vides les vitrines
une grande favorite concernée
et là non
toi tu perds en fait
les propos de drone non
plus mais compliqué quand même
en français 4 cavalier D7 est-ce qu'on
peut tenter un truc comme ça avec l'idée
dame C6 on reprend à 8 et remettre le
cavalier sur E5
on a perdu tous les avantages
malheureusement bah c'est pour essayer
de
non parce que en touche le fou G6 mais
il est passé important de cette position
mais si tu sais ce qui m'inquiète c'est
que il a fait son truc hystérique là de
tomber B3
[Musique]
forcés et maintenant il réfléchit il
m'inquiète tu sais
en fait il a pas du tout le dame trop en
fin de variante
un peu comme Murtas tu sais qui regarde
des fois quand il panique et tout d'un
coup tu vois son sourire à bientôt
paniquer tout d'un coup tu vois le
sourire sur ses lèvres
au dernier moment non bien sûr c'est la
Dolce
quotidienne quoi quotidienne juste
avec des cours
de parc
mais là je pense qu'il va tout trouver
parce que c'est tout forcé
ça c'est du bol c'est vraiment tout
forcé
et pourquoi pas cahier d'essai je viens
de poser la question il y a 30 secondes
ben on aurait pas dû à cette question
non mais on va pas jouer
une victoire éventuelle du Ding mais oui
Michel aussi qui vient voilà c'est
compliqué
ça m'inquiète là il réfléchit trop sur
ce coup
mon collègue Fab a un talent très
spécial de venir exactement au moment
qu'un
très spécial fantastique parce que ça me
donne l'occasion de de Me vaporer au
meilleur moment allez à toute j'espère à
la bonne note
en matière aurait pu être raté quoi
on a le FAP qui arrive
salut tout le monde
c'est pas grave elle partira après
le chat noir bah ouais je sais pas si
c'est chat noir ou pas femme parce que
là la position elle va encore mais oui
c'était étonnant le après Caval c'est 5
le Coutras tour B3 nous a étonné on
pensait qu'il allait rentrer dans cette
position
qui est bien à long terme pour les
blancs
ouais
et du coup et du coup il est rentré dans
tour B3 qui est un peu compliqué il faut
qu'il repartent à trois c'est ça
ouais bon ça
pardon après cavalier à 5 tu reprends le
5 dame F6 bon repartir c'est pas non
plus le coup de l'année le coup de
l'année pour attaquer le cavalier au
passage en plus et les parents sont
assez compliquées et ces quatre vous
prend ces quatre décès
cavalier prend B7 on regardait tour
reprend dame prend dame prend H4 on n'y
a pas trop cru mais c'est quand même une
option c'est quoi c'est Dame 5 temps V8
mais nous on a pensé à ça plutôt enfin
on a regardé plutôt ce truc là
et là à la fin de la fin de la fin il y
a Adam 3 ok il faut l'avoir sinon tu
perds
en tout cas
[Musique]
qu'un coup unique à trouver mais bon il
y a plein de variantes mais il y en
avait une autre tout à l'heure il y
avait un autre dame 3 mais je crois que
c'est ça il dit des pro E5 plutôt ouais
mais bon enfin on a pas trop aimé mais
peut-être fou quoi
[Musique]
c'est sûr que tu es
bon ok il est bien enfin il est bien
mais
ferme la porte non non c'est sûr qu'il
est bien c'est certain sa femme
mais bon c'est pas facile
ah non
mais bon
écoute tu fais ça parti quoi non mais
c'est sûr que si tu as
tous les coups de l'ordi
non mais pour l'instant du coup il joue
bien
encore une fois ils mettent en danger
avec les Blancs quoi ouais mais là on
était choqué avec Vlad de ne pas
franchement
bon je sais pourquoi pas
parce que c'est mais mon cavalier 5 qui
avait les 7 à 4 et faire à 6 et cavalier
17 et laisser ça c'est quand même tu
dois tout fixer
ça c'est quand même connu dans cette
structure que c'est le temps que tu veux
éviter parce que bon après je peux
ressent mais j'imaginais qu'il y a que
les blancs en fait elle est joué les
lames facile
il a super bien joué
bon il va tenté le 5 n'est pas en fait
cinq c'est rien quand même en fait il a
passé à cause de ça
il évite les attaques mais tu pouvais
pas parce qu'il y avait tout droit mais
là disons et on avait regardé tout re 8
B4 et E5
donc quand bien même tu arrives à faire
le 5 c'est pas terrible
non mais ça c'est connu comme truc que
tu veux dire
et c'est systématiquement horrible avec
les noirs
c'est un plan vraiment connu connu donc
c'était bizarre qu'il est laissé aussi
facilement alors que tu te le prennes
c'est une chose mais il a vraiment
donné quoi
donc ça c'était étonnant
et après ça arrive
de faire des erreurs
bon on va voir mais ça m'inquiète là
qu'il est fait ce tourber 3 tu reprends
le 5 aussi vite et qui tant que
maintenant
comme s'il avait raté quelque chose
ouais oui bien sûr je sais pas on va
voir c'est vrai que c'est le moment
assez important en fait ouais mais du
coup le moment important il est là
mais tu choisis entre B4 trop ça
et après tu
parce que là B4 à vrai dire c'est très
bien aussi fin il fait il fait 4 moi
j'avais tout rat c'est pas le premier
coup de l'ordi mais j'aurais fait ça
tu es quand même nettement mieux là
ouais faut encore gagner mais oui
c'est 5 éternel qui va attaquer B7 et tu
peux jamais trop ton débarrasser si tu
prends tu feras des prends et tu auras
une pression sur la colonne B
et puis en plus tu as plus de qualité
donc c'est vraiment difficile de le
supprimer donc ça c'est un net avantage
et
mais ok
très bien aussi mais genre ce qui
m'inquiète c'est qu'il réfléchissent
après dans mes fils c'est tout en fait
ça fait très longtemps là
je sais pas après peut-être qu'il avait
un autre truc dans mes fils mais quoi
parce que dame c'est ça donne des si tu
parles à dames
ouais
c'est pour ça que c'est étonnant
mais
je préfère te mettre non mais c'est pas
la question de ce qui préfère en fait
c'est qu'il faut avoir les coups en fait
alors il peut préférer ce qu'il veut
mais si t'as pas les coups c'est
toujours au hasard quoi
moi c'est bon non ça va black t'inquiète
non c'est bon c'est bon
peut-être on reprend à 8 d'abord
ouais mais le truc c'est que sur Toura 3
de toute façon tu reprends le sein qui a
pu en prendre et c'est ah peut-être il y
a des
quatre
et compagnie après
encore mieux et ça doit pas être ça peut
être la seule option je pense
d'apprendre 5 c'est très bien aussi que
tu forces plus ou moins d'apprendre du
coup puis on prend
car elle est ici c'est
même juste F4 et tu vas gagner un pion
là quelque part et j'ai 4 et Machin
ouais non ça a l'air bien partout
j'aurais même pas pensé en fait tu
donnes la colonne il va retourner il va
te contrer etc
t'as pas très envie ouais
mais c'est ça qui est incroyable
non parce que bizarre c'est qu'il joue
pas le coup que toute façon il doit
jouer ouais mais c'est qui soit
participé
un blocage là mais bon on avait déjà je
peux pas parler longtemps
c'est pas très grave au cas où hein s'il
y avait là-dessous
c'est très grave Fab tout est grave
sinon c'est tombé 4 je vois pas la
logique du coup en fait
tu t'enferme non
c'était vraiment sûr
je dirais la question elle est plus
après cavalier C4 vous prend ses Cader
qui a été tempo mon fou français 4 a
priori c'est forcé hein
mais bon preding il peut être un peu
confiant c'est qu'on se met à jouer
tempo comme ça
c'est pas trop mon signe pour sa
position il joue vite ou quoi mais
c'était pas tempo quand il était gagnant
il vérifiez bien il était assez rapide
il a joué une partie il a pas il a pris
1 heure 20 quoi mais il t'enchaînait pas
les coups à vitesse de l'éclair donc
c'est que en fait il aime pas quand il
joue tempo c'est généralement signe de
position inférieure pour Yann
il a pas envie de voir ça en fait
on est actuellement 25e coup 37 minutes
ça suffit mais oui il faut pas jeter son
temps par les fenêtres quoi
ce qui peut y avoir un moment un peu
difficile dans 6-7 coups et ce serait
dommage qu'il lui reste que 10 minutes
quoi ouais en tout cas pas 30 secondes
ici très critique ou quoi donc on est au
25 où là il reste 15 il y a pas ça va
mais oui
oui non c'est pas enfin faut pas traîner
pour rien quoi
c'est forcé donc ce serait bien qu'il
continue à réfléchir pour avoir encore
un coup quoi
c'était pas le bon timing pour pour
partir côté Yann père de gratter encore
deux trois minutes
mais ça veut dire qu'il est vraiment
dégoûté Yann s'il est parti à ce
moment-là ce qui savait qu'il y aurait
qu'à y penser 4 mais il s'est quand même
levé
mais il veut pas voir ça mais c'est à
dire qu'il est dégoûté
ça veut dire qu'il est écœuré
incroyable ce match il y a encore une
égalisation
c'est fou hein
ça fait quoi 4 victoires en six parties
donc il a repris
et a priori on peut aller bouffer Bessat
[Musique]
ou F4 là après sinon il y avait le vent
de
il était trop particulier ce match je
peux pas trop le prendre en compte bon
le problème c'est qu'il y a déjà une
victoire par forfait
mais bon après c'est la vie quoi enfin
je sais mais c'est tellement différent
[Musique]
mais F4 il peut faire
s'il veut juste une domination dans la
position
moi j'aurais plutôt fait F4
bon après je sais pas ce que j'aurais
fait avec beaucoup de temps à la pendule
mais tu me laisses pas trop de temps
j'irai plutôt sur F4 qui prend B7 ou je
sais pas forcément sûr de conserver B2
et compagnie quoi
bah après tout dépend ouais après ça
dépend ce que tu as validé ou pas validé
par le calcul quoi oui non bien sûr
mais du coup bon ce qui a de bien ce
qu'il a de deux bonnes options quoi
allez il peut pas trop se tromper je
pense
donc bon mais il devrait à mon avis je
veux quand même assez relativement
rapidement tout ça fait long enfin
logiquement ça fait longtemps qu'ils
sont en train de calculer cette position
on a regardé donc ouais normalement
c'est
prise B7 ouais F4 c'est les deux coups
possibles à notre avis
bon après vous dire prise B7 si tu as
rien qui va pas autant prendre le
matériel quand tu peux
si tu as toutes les variantes oui
F4 c'est quoi la suite j'aime bien en
fait mais ce qu'il y a une suite ou bon
peu importe
mais pas tout à l'heure parce qu'il
disait que ça laisse un rêve au noir
cette [__] le fou en C6 et
contre-attaquer sur G2
ouais mais bon parce que c'est
réalisable
par exemple c'est vrai que du coup si tu
arrives à calculer quel prend B7 il vaut
mieux prendre B7
donc aucun des coups qu'on a dit mais
peut-être que ça va ressembler
de trouver c'est terrible
donc si on fait réagir il y a père pète
et si on fait damage quoi
[Musique]
idem D8 enfin je veux dire
du coup moi je vais regarder ah à tourin
il y a H5 donc
ça doit être encore peut-être moins
l'avantage en fait il fait chier lors
des trucs que des trucs de fouine
parce que ça a l'air très fort
[Musique]
je pense pas que ce soit à trouver
c'est hyper dur bon c'est très très dur
quand même mais tu sais quoi il peut
peut-être trouver le dépôt ouais je
pense pas
bah en fait le problème
en fait le reste s'aper sur le champ ah
c'est pas de bol pour Ding ah là c'est
vraiment pas de chance et ça dépend
aussi de
quelque part je sais pas faut H7 disons
maintenant tu vas prendre B7 et tu as la
même en net mieux c'est une version très
améliorée bah le fou rire il y a déjà il
y aura une des maths du couloir et puis
le pion est déjà en H5 il y a plus de
dame pour H4 qui gênaient tout à l'heure
et du coup quand tu fais tout reprendre
à me prendre c'est oui tu as éliminé ton
frère
c'est pas de bol
il y croit enfin si en fait il veut pas
voir sa position qui veut jouer tempo il
va pas faire mais si réfléchit
franchement il peut l'avoir enfin il
voit très vite ce genre de conneries
il est bon pour ça
bah c'est son point fort
contre ne pas justement il gagnait pas
les trucs qui gagnent pas les trucs
gagnants parce que l'autre s'en sort
tout le temps
il veut peut-être gagner de manière trop
direct en fait
mais attends je suis quand même en train
de me poser une question parce que cette
position là
bonne chance
et super ouais j'ai 8 tours ici et tu as
plus toutes les finales de pions sont
perdants donc tu peux pas
pour B8
et si tu fais ouais mais si tu fais B5
on peut faire tourner
ok c'est étonnant l'ordi il aime pas
tant que ça ouais mais tu rentres pas là
dedans de getter de cœur non et surtout
que ton F7 du coup c'était une connerie
d'après ce que j'ai cru voir de la jauge
même si ça me paraissait logique
il fait tout seul
parce que oui si toute façon le roi sort
oui oui non non en fait c'est logique
juste c'est étonnant mais c'est logique
ce que là de toute façon il est obligé
de décaler la tour pour sortir le roi
mais si on va continuer à faire la
colère et donc on gagne juste un tempo
donc non non ça va
[Musique]
D8
G3 dames C5
d'ailleurs
oui il faut la voir ça va
donc pas besoin
bon alors est-ce que quoi et là tu es
bloqué
il a joué
mais c'était vraiment dur non c'est dur
mais en fait c'est qu'il a pas cherché
ouais
mais en fait après pour le coup c'est de
plus logique que tu te fous pas dans les
maps du couloir donc c'est probablement
le deuxième meilleur coup mais de loin
moins bon quoi après voilà comme je vous
dis je sais pas
ok en pratique qui trouve qui trouve pas
mais
si chaque jour le scénario en fait où ça
défend pas quoi ça défend pas
c'est étonnant bah normalement c'est
leur énorme point fort mais après c'est
des défenses à chaque fois extrêmement
difficile
je sais même pas si j'aurai songé à ça
mais c'est quand même pas invisible quoi
mais faut le chercher parce qu'en fait
tu le vois pas du premier coup d'œil
mais c'est sûr qu'en fait si tu envisage
pas
on n'a pas encore les temps de réflexion
mais il a il a réfléchi moins de 10
minutes ça c'est clair ah oui non enfin
en haut si lac de cou candidats tous ces
deux et qui s'arrête là il va pas dire
autre chose mais 6 minutes c'est très
peu non parce qu'il a pas cherché à voir
autre chose
[Musique]
mais moi il faut quand même une mise à
jour de ce qu'ils peuvent trouver ou pas
trouvé tu vois on sait pas en fait on
sait plus
ça ça me paraissait vraiment dur
personnellement
en fait
ouais c'était complexe
je sais pas enfin oui mais bon
non mais le problème en fait c'est
que je sais pas combien en fait si tu
acceptes la situation comme ça c'est
plus ou moins tu as déjà perdu si tu
joues une partie normale tu es trop mal
quoi dans la position
honnêtement si on voit la séquence elle
est quand même enfin elle est quand même
ultra dure non mais c'est ultra dur mais
en fait si tu as le thème te dire ah
[__] j'ai peut-être échec si tu as ça
en fait et que tu t'arrêtes à la F3 tu
peux recommencer avec E1 E5 ouais ouais
bien sûr et OK
bon ben voilà on en parle plus mais
de quoi c'est pas non plus non c'est
ultra dur mais pas le le truc étonnant
c'est surtout qu'il a pas cherché en
fait c'est ça il a en fait il a pas
cherché
tu lui mets ça en exercice il va trouver
mais en fait je sais pas comment dire en
fait quand tu es si mal faut que le
cours de la partie change bah sinon tu
vas perdre gentiment comme dinguer par
exemple tu vas perdre de gaieté de cœur
non mais tu vois hier en fait tu vois
que tes mains et tu fais rien et puis
bah tu perds écraser et comme
après il a peut-être peur comme toi lui
ôter le pain de la bouche il s'est dit
il a fait une bonne partie si je fais
tout reprendre le 5 je lui hot le pain
de la bouche
et
ouais tu vois je sais pas
et la première victoire de Ding sur
l'anglaise
ouais bon au moins il a acheté en D4 de
changer un truc juste bon c'était trop
évident pour reprendre et mais
tu reprends le 5 moi ça me paraît quand
même enfin c'est range ultra dur
non mais c'est juste qu'il a parlé du
coup
tellement dur en tout cas bien joué Ding
donc il a pris ça toi
pardon pardon mon Fab et donc bien sûr
H5 c'est bien joué puisqu'il a il aime
trop il a une meilleure position et donc
maintenant tu retournes il peut vraiment
jouer dame prend tranquillement la dame
va protéger dame B6 cavalier B6 dam
prend B2 cavalier prend C4 Damsin et
chèque crois H2
et alors l'ordi te dit pas du tout il te
dit que maintenant il y a fout des trois
ah et la différence c'est comment ta
dame D1 protège le fouet donc en fait
faute en fait la finesse des États-Unis
très très grave donc donc
tu peux jouer
ok donc
c'est pas plus simple que l'autre c'est
vite là qui bon qui est trouvable qui
est toujours dehors dans ce sens là
ouais mais qui est trouvable
c'est pas impossible
quoi mais le cavalier 8 pour les mettre
sur G7 je sais pas à chaque fois c'est
le cerveau est moins fait pour ça quoi
beaucoup plus trouvable que le temps
on verra
donc en tout cas il a fait dame
donc il a pas pris le 5 donc c'est
cavaliers
mais encore une fois peut-être il faut
pas prendre c'est la même enfin le même
truc
en fait la finesse on n'était pas une
mais en fait du coup dans le 5 si tu as
cavalier 8 ça devient logique
ouais et d'ailleurs
si on fait cavalier vite là c'est dames
c'est un objet 5
c'est bizarre
[Musique]
bon ok donc attends il est vraiment
rentré dans un truc ultra complexe
qualité
alors
et tu as pas le dame c'est ah tu as pas
d'âme sœur en fait la différence tout à
l'heure c'est qu'on doit perdre la tour
à 3 et là maintenant on va juste
défendre la diagonales
mais on est bien quand même du coup sur
cavalier 8 l'idée c'est top 3 8 1 9 4 et
on fait perpète mais du coup ok on fera
plus qu'il y avait 8 à ce moment là
mais
et là ça va le pion H5 est bien placé
parce qu'on le défend et est-ce que
c'est un coup aussi ou pas
mais je veux dire parce que quand on est
bien droit à nu quoi
c'est pas mal quoi
c'est ultra complexe bon on a beaucoup
de bonnes branche en fait ça va en fait
grâce à ce qui avait lieu 8 c'est un
beau mais le truc
il est pas du tout en Contrôle
extrêmement complexe donc c'est normal
aussi mais j'ai peur que ça se joue sur
un coup de dés
si il a le bon jeu
pour 12 coups facile
[Musique]
et admettons qui se trompe mais qui
fasse 5 ça fait quoi enfin juste là je
me questionne
tu es obligé de faire dame prendre B2
ouais bon là tu te trait tout de suite
rebouffer le truc ça tu peux pas donc
faut pas se tromper
moi et après d'un autre côté c'est
d'autant plus facile de pas se tromper
et si tu prends 8 d'abord ça me paraît
complètement illogique
vraiment
si tu compares pas
tu peux si l'autre tu vois rien mais
ça
excuse-moi dame prend ça et toi c'est là
le moment difficile parce que
des trois ou trois
après tu après
[Musique]
délié oui on s'en fout mais j'ai pas
trop qu'elle t'aime pour gagner vraiment
bon
[Musique]
c'est terrible
mais je sais pas trop
c'est les doigts
peut-être ça gagne mais peut-être même
ça quand tu te dis que tu peux faire
mais c'est inquiétant parce que
il a beaucoup de faux amis là
ok
les amis c'est ça c'est évident et ici
c'est juste évident
parce que sur dame prend B2 il y a tout
reprend 8 échecs tu reprends qu'il y
avait les prendre asmath donc il y a pas
le temps de récupérer la tour à trois
donc il va il va prendre la fenêtre ça y
est c'est jouer
pour qu'on s'attend à prendre alors il
peut prendre du pion ouais ouais
peut-être plus simple en fait si il fait
ça enfin c'est pas gagné non plus mais
ça a une bonne gueule qui ait des soucis
il est très beau quoi la tour à 5 et
elle bloque elle défend tu peux la
ramener en jeu via je sais pas c'est
simple
finalement parce que tu as pas réussi
non mais tu vois
introduire un truc c'est hyper
questionnable si c'est bon
en réalité quand il réfléchit tu as
plein de lignes tu serais content
d'avoir l'option H4 le four aussi c'est
une
voix c'est qu'on se prend plus de
perpète plus de trucs quand on a mal
[Musique]
ok
on va voir
après ça se joue sur est-ce que ta
cavalier tout pas mais cavaliers 8 là
quand même Fab bon c'est pas non plus
enfin il a deux coups du truc quoi
on a déjà vu l'exemple de cramique qui
est connu quoi
en fait d'ailleurs et donc c'était
cavagnon F8
donc ça peut arriver quoi tu peux juste
ne pas avoir
je vais pas me risquer un tweet là trop
risqué
mais bon les deux prises sont pas mal
sûrement une dame prend et plus fort
objectif effectivement mais puis on
prend j'aime bien quand même donc je
veux dire il peut choisir celui qui veut
dans les deux cas c'est pas mal après
ouais faudra faire gaffe à un époque il
peut s'activer même avec son pion a
poussé un peu
défendre de l'autre côté mais
domine enfin c'est une bonne partie ça
il peut vraiment la voir
oui ça c'est vraiment dur à jouer
mais en fait si je vois ça et je vois
dame j'ai trois pions le 5 du premier
coup d'oeil je me dis que les deux sont
très bien j'ai du mal à me dire lequel
je préfère
les moins bien tenu après qui va me
l'attaquer mais j'ai cavalier 8 en fait
c'est ça
il fait tellement mal
[Musique]
pas trop de doute quoi
c'est six dame F6 3b7 ouais bon c'est
pas la variante la plus dure de l'année
plus fort mais même s'il prend du pion
c'est pas c'est pas la fin des chances
de Game quoi non non clairement mais
c'est pour ça que c'est dur de trouver
le meilleur coup là tu as deux bons
choix enfin tu en as un très très bon et
un juste bien quoi
en tout cas c'est une partie encore
passionnante aujourd'hui il y a que des
belles parties en Championnat du Monde
dans ma skate bien ce qui se font pas
sécher l'ouverture
et ils se font sécher l'ouverture mais
en fait ils réussir
sa laisser l'autre chez sécher
l'ouverture enfin ouais mais à faire
jouer l'adversaire dans une position où
il joue mal enfin il y a pas de nulle
forfait quoi c'est ça joue non parce
qu'il réussisse vraiment à jouer le
style
[Musique]
ils obtiennent rien avec les Blancs
genre jamais personne n'arrive à faire à
Carson en fait hein parce qu'il est trop
universel Carson toi tu peux pas lui
mettre de position
jamais mal après l'ouverture même pas un
peu souffrir quasiment quoi il a eu la
chaise nikov une fois mais la difficulté
qu'on garde c'est que en fait Carlsen a
trouve une position qui joue mal
il faut lui attaquer loin
[Musique]
universel tellement fort partout Magnus
que c'est juste que tu peux pas en fait
mais prenons mieux préparer en fait
aussi ouais bah c'est sûr bah il a
beaucoup plus d'argent depuis beaucoup
plus longtemps et en fait tu le touches
pas enfin non tu peux pas il a
intouchable comme verratti ou Motta
sont très intouchables complètement
on va voir ce qu'il a dit
UE c'est l'exemple qu'on n'est pas
obligé d'avoir de répertoire non mais en
fait c'est une légende que Magnus c'est
mal préparé du monde depuis très
longtemps je suis très mal préparé c'est
beaucoup il s'est foutu de la gueule de
tout le monde avec ce truc là les gens
ils ont cru pendant un moment je crois
malheureusement malheureusement
[Musique]
qu'il a pas travaillé quoi en fait c'est
ça le truc
et donc il jouait des petits machins
mais on sent très bien son petit machin
très bien joué là de la part de Ding
il a resserré la vis il a le cavalier 8
évidemment
non mais probablement que
on est bon franchement en fait ce qu'il
avait déjà tout ça en jouant H5
il vérifie en fait quand il est là il se
regarde mais
oui donc faut qu'il joue thoracique
et qui est le premier cas c'était pas là
on avait la finale quand même
c'était là où tu étais quoi
ok bah il peut se tromper en fait du
coup non non
je sais pas comment dire non mais si tu
attends
c'est là qu'il faut avoir tout à 5 c'est
la tour à 5 c'est qu'il a tout
mais il peut très bien faire cavalier
français 4 et pas avoir et ça serait pas
fini non plus d'échange mais parce qu'il
aura les doigts et tout ça c'est pas
complètement fini mais bon cavaler à 5
quand on voit la ligne tu auras 5 pardon
fout D3 disons c'est logique comme coup
quand même B12
tu as l'air très bien là pas que dame G5
pour pas te faire mater
possible donc c'est trop frais c'est le
truc qu'on avait
il est pas parti dans le bon truc tout
ça parce que le pion en H5
ouais ouais bon je sais pas si simple
l'autre enfin il y avait un truc simple
avec
faut avoir tout ça
ouais c'est quoi la différence
non mais c'est très dur là c'est
franchement
c'est calculé
et il s'est levé donc c'est à dire qu'il
arroache 7 à mon avis
mais il va avoir Damien
et
[Musique]
non parce que des fois en fait quand il
doit vraiment calculer et qu'il est en
forme il fait bien genre tu te souviens
la défense contre karwana au candidat
quand il se prend nouveauté machin il
t'a joué tous les seuls
il s'en fout il est là c'est très très
impressionnant mesdames et messieurs
20 minutes 20 minutes pour 10 coups ça
devrait passer parce que cette dame 1 je
crois que ça gagne le pion C4 en force
[Musique]
5 peut-être donc je sais pas
et puis bah tu es bien quoi
tu reviens vers E5 bon ça ça va aller là
ok allez Dingo oh il peut régaliser
quand même trois partout ce serait
incroyable Fab ce serait incroyable
une époque il doit pas être bien
exactement
il perdure ouais mais il va la voir
il va l'avoir Fab
le truc
sinon tu rentres pas dans tout ça si tu
l'as pas en fait
déjà
un truc ou c'est logique on va dire
c'est que vas-y tu peux faire
si tu fais d'un E3 et qui a fout des
trois en fait tu défends plus les trois
donc ça te saoule quoi alors que avec
trois même si t'as pas qui est pensé 4
bons qui calme pas trop dur là pour le
coup mais je veux dire fout des trois tu
défends ton truc et tu as un coup
toutes les menaces en fait finalement
elle est plus logique ici quoi
genre 8
dame B1 roi H2 dame B8 un peu comme
comme hier
mais bon on échange on joue la finale
d'apprendre et ses seins
comme ça
[Musique]
c'est pas facile ça
calcule parce qu'elle est forcée donc
B3 j'imagine
ça va vite quand même
c'est un visage même pas et si je pousse
enfin on va commencer par faire ton F2
des 6 x 4
ok mais ça c'est et tour des cinq je
vais pas gagner quoi
simplement
j'avais pas et l'autre tour des cinq
c'est quoi le truc là ici tu aurais 5
direct
et il te faisait exactement la même idée
c'est introuvable non donc ça va
bon surtout que on n'est pas obligé de
possession des comme un con et donner F2
mais c'était le truc qu'on l'a regardé
parce que
[Musique]
bon tu as envie quoi enfin déjà tu
regardes
de fou et 4 tours jet d'oeuf qui a fou
F5 en fin de variante c'est impossible à
voir non mais en plus ça se trouve on
fait Roger trois ou F3
en fait de toute façon avec les Noirs tu
calcules ton B3 C3 D6 parce que les
Noirs il doit aussi calculer pour
trouver
il est revenu
je pense ça va gagner parce qu'en fait
les défenses elles sont dures à trouver
aussi
mais en plus il y a rien enfin il y a un
clean il y a aucune défense qui qui
défend vraiment c'est qu'il y a aucune
défense qui défend à 100% et en plus les
trucs qui sont vraiment durs pour les
blancs ils sont tout aussi dur pour les
noirs
bah la preuve il a pas trouvé le dôme
et qui pour le coup t'es pas introuvable
je pense toujours mais bon très très dur
quand même
d'ailleurs c'est Ding qui est revenu et
pas et pas n'est pas
ça réfléchit
côté ligne mais 20 minutes normalement
ça devrait lui suffire pour trouver les
coups parce que là c'est une position
dont il s'est bien imprégné et les coups
noirs sont un peu forcés
il peut pas lui arriver une tuaasse un
coup qui est en fait
j'en peux plus parce qu'on me dit qu'il
y a mate en un alors
attends c'était sur fouder 3 cavaliers 8
dame B1 roi H2 on nous dit toute la
valentinfos c'est à cause de ma t-en un
on est vraiment mauvais mais merde on
veut pas
j'arrive pas à cliquer
il y a des nuls
trop dur
er
c'est juste un clouage
le jeu est buggé
c'est trop
bon alors
comment ça va continuer côté Yann
en fait
mais peut-être que Yann il avait pas
tout ça peut-être qu'il était confiant
de mes deux
la confiance en toi
au hasard
en tout cas c'est une très très belle
partie nouvelle fois ça nous réconcilie
un peu avec les matchs de championnat du
monde toutes ces tous ces spectacle
c'est vrai il était tellement au dessus
des autres mais finalement les matchs il
a rarement mené en match championnat du
monde puisqu'il a jamais mené contre
karwana j'avais mené contre caryakin
et puis il a gagné la partie longue et
fin du match
non mais le truc enfin je sais pas il
arrive à imposer son style en fait plus
ou moins carnet dans les matchs
c'est prépa était forte
et là tu as l'impression que je sais pas
ouais c'est beaucoup plus fragile les
prépas
peut-être qu'ils sont peut-être que
Magnus était encore nettement mieux
préparé que ce qu'on a pensé encore plus
encore plus ouais ça va mais
[Musique]
d'ouverture que dans les matchs de scène
car la partie ouais mais ça c'est sûr
oui mais bon il se trouve
après il est pas dominé du tout ben non
non puis bon c'est première partie du
premier match championnat du monde que
tu joues on voit que ça a été fragile
côté Ding aussi
oui il faut qu'il rentre dans le match
de toute façon pour le coup Magnus en
plus dans tous les temps infirmé qui
fait
souvent il démarre doucement
puis au moins il chauffe et puis
il a jamais été en danger Magnus dans
les matchs par contre caryakine c'est
plus que danger quoi bah oui tu es
proche de perte contre cajouana c'est
quand même des partages on peut pas dire
que Magnus il est gagné ses matchs de
championnat du monde facilement enfin
certains cela même celui qu'on trade il
fait une grosse gaffe ah non de la voix
pas mais si à nom de voix c'est un autre
match
dingue de pas voir aussi d'ailleurs ça
c'était fou hein parce que pas dur
et qu'on tenait peau et il est un peu
derrière dans les six premières ouais
mais bon après par contre lui dès qu'il
a gagné une et il a gagné une il a fait
exploser une pause alors que l'inverse
aurait pas été vrai non
et contrats
il a eu un petit creux générationnel
Magnus au début
c'est étonnant qui rejoint au nom de la
deuxième fois en fait ça personne
s'attendait moi sûrement pas
parce que oui donc il y a le match de
ok très bien donc il est champion du
monde bravo et après il y a des
candidats qui qui se rejoignent pas
longtemps après quoi et du coup à Nantes
va les jouer on sait pas pourquoi il
joue qu'en fait parce que on se dit oui
bon ça il prend plus ou moins sa
retraite et il a pu son titre de
champion du monde et leur gagnera jamais
mais en fait il regagne les candidats
quoi non juste six mois après et c'est
incroyable enfin je veux dire avant le
tournoi à personne aurait misé un copain
quoi
et en plus si ça la remotivé parce
qu'après il a gagné des
remis après
il a gagné des beaux tournois je me
souviens de peut-être un chemisier ou je
sais plus où enfin
et donc il est revenu une deuxième match
il a le spot sur le roi des deux quoi
et il l'a pas et puis du coup ouais mais
il aurait fait le match c'était pas il
aurait pas été pareil donc on peut pas
dire que Magnus il est pas évidemment il
est très dominant parce qu'il a gagné 5
matchs championnats du monde c'est
impressionnant c'est pas on n'est pas là
pour minimiser cette performance mais
dire qu'il a écrasé tous les matchs
c'est pas écrasé quoi
et ce contrat non
il a pas d'amour il a pas d'amour
la tuile la tuile ou pas enfin bon ok
évidemment le module kiff moyen mais bon
je reste
plutôt confiant pour lui parce que bon
la tour elle va s'activer la taxe on le
masque en français 4 en fait et puis on
va vouloir cavalier 7 et jouer pour le
match
elle est centrale elle défend bien le
roi il y a pas les perpettes elle défend
H5 donc je veux dire je comprends
humainement le truc
ouais c'est complètement compréhensible
parce que dame français 3 donc il faut
que tu as envie de regarder c'est un
pion en un c'est normal bon là
[Musique]
c'est le premier truc que j'ai envie de
regarder
l'âme des deux évasion
ok mais attends cavalier F7 ça marche
pas
à cause de toi-même en fait on va s'en
bouffer dans toutes les ventes par leur
dites celle-là
mais j'ai peur qu'il s'en prennent à un
moment donné
question ouais mais ok et si je fais
torcer ça en fait et pas qu'elle F7
parce qu'en fait plus solide quoi pour
C4 C7
ok donc chaque fois il défend un kf6 il
veut nous décaler la dame faire dameh5
qui est moins bien placé quoi
bon ok donc tu en penses C4 ça doit pas
être génial
certains direct
parce que il a pas son tour 8 pour
l'instant le cadavre
pour toucher C1 et du coup ok courant de
la tour on fait quoi et là on a parce
que ah et sur dame c'est un roi de tour
8 je voulais cavaliers 5 mais j'ai pas
elles vont dame j'ai 3 OK
mais comment on est bien je trouve mais
bon ok ça chauffe un peu quoi
de partout on peut perdre en fait on
peut perdre même
on peut perdre on peut gagner
très compliqué du coup
[Musique]
il est vraiment rentré dans un truc
sur le film sur le fil ouais après c'est
pas vraiment la faute moi c'est pas là
les tours c'est 5 et tout c'est
tellement dur
que ça me surprend pas mais ce que je
trouve encore dommage c'est d'être
rentré dans le Tour B3 du coup ah oui
mais bon peut-être entendu aussi avec
ton B3 avec B4 non mais c'est sûr mais
genre si c'est aussi chaud partout
dommage je veux pas jouer le
mais H5 du coup je sais pas quoi en
penser c'est vrai
on se prend des perpettes partout c'est
chiant mais en fait quand on voit son
idée là d'aller attaquer la 7e tu es
content que j'ai pas de fonges et 6 quoi
mais bon peut-être tu aurais pu le
garder sous le coude et le faire un
moment que ça te semble le plus
important j'en sais rien
facile à dire
[Musique]
bon après écoutez c'est compliqué je
sais pas il peut tout se passe enfin
plutôt quand même parce qu'il y a quand
même beaucoup de défense sur des
perpettes plutôt toujours dignes favoris
mais bon c'est pas fait
le tweet n'est pas parti encore quoi
loin de là
attends
8 je suis en train d'allumer
OK
et 8 de nouveau à cause du truc on
commence à le connaître
mais là peut-être même la finale
elle est facile je pense
je sais pas à quel point c'est facile
mais
bon ça peut elles ont des têtes détenu
prêchez pas tu peux trouver des exemples
tu vas pouvoir gagner à 6 je pense
c'est 5 et tu vas d'une manière X Y avec
Boufféré
mais du coup est-ce que je reviens un
petit peu F5 et tu pourras pas parce que
regarder d'ailleurs c'est un coup bon ça
fait chier face d'un problème de passe
du coup on perd nos espoirs
donc bon ok
je crois c'est Dame des deux très
étonnant
avec ça en fait
j'aurais tellement confiance
est-ce que
[Musique]
en fait il utilise sa tour a pour
t'envoyer le pion
passive d'un coup elle devient bien
placé quoi mais bon tu as encore kévis
quand même
et il te fait tourner vite maintenant
oui bon si c'est comme ça c'est comme ça
quoi
on va quand même la joie un petit peu
encore
[Musique]
C7 et si la défense c'est damné de tout
rêve 7
parce que celle-là
ça j'ai l'impression que je suis
complètement gagnant je vais quand même
te bouffer c'est et pousser le pion
autour
bravo enfin bravo bravo non mais
va te faire [__]
non mais c'est trop les défenses non
mais non mais du coup je suis plutôt
team
fut team dames C3 en fait
[Musique]
non mais c'est beaucoup trop les gens
ont raison dans le chat ok il te fait
machin à 5 fouder
et c'est encore ce [__] de pion H5
dans toutes les variantes et ce qui est
marrant
c'est que la partie où j'ai gagné contre
camski salut
de merde peu importe mais c'est un truc
avec il a foutu cette même structure et
c'est un fou des 7 x 8 x 5 qui le bas
[__] de stock fiche de merde
mais là c'est marrant c'est encore ce
[__] de système de Londres un peu en
H5 qui se fait bouffer
bah c'est marrant quoi enfin marrant
c'est marrant on a rien à [__] non
plus mais
et pour le coup bon
d'un procès droit ça a l'air d'être
vraiment le seul coup d'après leur dire
par contre
après c'est pas super étonnant non plus
parce que c'est vrai que c'est quatre
c'est pas si clair
[Musique]
il a joué il a joué
ça va être cool non mais il va faire à 5
ah sur ce contre jeu avec le pion a pour
un joueur de greenfeld ça donne envie en
fait ça
coupe la dame vas-y à 3 on fait les
idiots tours C7 menace
et du coup
je sais pas ça mon hyper confiant parce
que j'ai l'impression qu'on gagne des
tempos
hyper logique ok bon il veut que sur ton
C7 il est MG5 mais bon on va lui faire
un F4 un jour non les gens on peut
bouffer ces quatre jours de merde il va
dégager et après j'avais le coup j'avais
la ligne 3
et question
subsidiaire est-ce que au lieu de ça
j'avais donc c'est facile est-ce qu'au
lieu de tout ça enfin
est-ce que F4 aussi c'est un coup
alors il se trouve que non parce que
je comprends
non mais en réalité pas ça
il bouge et tu fais cavalier 3 tu
touches là tu bloques ça
quand même enfin
tu sens que c'est sa case tu redescends
le roi tu bloques tout
mais ça va être peinard je pense ça va
être peinard ça fait Punto là ça sent
bon parce que c'est des coups très
humain maintenant ça parle tweet
je suis un peu quand même
mais oui dame G3 qui est C4 cavaluer 3
tu sens que
c'est stable ça défend tout ça touche le
fou tu sens que tu vas Ken
mais
c'est encore mal défendu
dur de critiquer quand même sur cette
partie c'était compliqué moi je suis
plus critique sur le A6 au début de
laisser la casser 5 et tout
parce que là les varans de combat avec
Dame français
on n'est pas eu une seule finale c'est
bizarre quand même quoi oui mais en fait
j'ai compris pour avoir des beaux matchs
juste pour prendre des mecs qui savent
pas défendre non mais c'est pas facile
mais c'est plein mais un moment j'ai on
te demande d'être champion du monde donc
forcément tu l'as fait un truc pas
facile quoi
si c'est juste
quand même cette partie là
me prend ces trois je te dis pas que tu
vas défendre et faire nul parce que tous
les trucs qu'on a eu de tu vas finir par
perdre mais tu tu barbelis ce que tu
peux barbelé
on se cache j'aime beaucoup les parties
de ce championnat du monde en plus elle
est belle partie pour des livres ouais
chaque fois à chaque fois ouais on
pourrait faire un livre sur ce match
mais après enfin moi je me plains pas
enfin voilà il est très cool à suivre ça
joue quand même pas mal vu j'aime bien
aimé que ça défende un peu mieux
justement que les gains soient plus durs
à obtenir parfois peut-être ça viendra
mais en fait après ils ont des idées
avec les blancs ils sont ils sont
chiants enfin chaque fois les noirs et
donc c'est ok c'est agréable on sait
jamais à quoi s'attendre chaque fois tu
dis tiens bon ça il prend le dessus il
va alors attends dessus de rien quoi en
fait ouais non non je me disais à 5
est-ce que il peut pas y avoir un faux
amis genre là il y a dame G5
non mais c'est logique ça c'est trop
logique là c'est pas que c'est
non mais le deuxième truc logique c'est
Fiat évidemment mais si Dame D1 est
chiant et c'est le cas bon bah tu les
limites
c'est un coup candidat quoi
il y a une différence il a un coup là F4
je sais pas mais l'autre me paraît trop
loin
F2 donc cavalier va être tenu tu vas te
faire je sais pas comment dire en fait
oui
mais voilà non mais je veux bien mais je
vais reparle que là tu as quand même non
mais là c'est fin c'est trop clair là
c'est bien c'était trop peinard en fait
ça ça protège ça ça protège ça il y a
plus d'échec en F4 tout d'un coup j'ai
l'impression que tu as réglé tout tes
problèmes plutôt fin c'est sûr que en
blé de son belette tu fais ça et bon et
d'ailleurs quand tu fais ça
qu'est-ce que il peut ne pas perdre en 5
coups
et il passe le laisser mater
du coup
ça c'est quand même la Valentin
le boulot mais ça sent très bon parce
que il a 7e rangé faible on a le
cavalier qui est bien on a le pion
dépassé et c'est beaucoup de choses tout
ça
tant pis
ça c'est le pire scénario que tu puisses
avoir après cavalier 3 ça se trouve
et du coup et le scénario max c'est Dame
F4 ici intermédiaire
[Musique]
oui
non mais oui
il y a pas de comparaison on va te faire
les touristes et donc tu dis ouais bon
et du coup le cavalier pas protégé sous
pression enfin tu sens que là si tu
pouvais jouer F2 tu serais trésor en
fait
OK
mais
elle était bien là
tu défends bien ta diagonale du roi
et là tu es sur une case du Fou donc
franchement après le problème c'est que
c'est le truc le plus logique et ses
Bacqué par l'ordi donc c'est sûr que
maintenant pour nous c'est évident
non mais il va probablement compliqué
[Musique]
et puis après tu es stable tu es bien
quoi c'est le truc le plus simple
c'est la difficulté des échecs c'est des
fois c'est le truc le plus simple et le
plus harmonieux qui est le mieux et pas
toujours des fois c'est complètement de
la merde
mais bon c'est de la merde c'est juste
qu'il y a une pointe tactique
t'es quand même tellement dégoûté quand
tu as refusé le truc le plus logique
ce que tu gagnes un peu au passage
au-delà de l'attaque sur le roi
mais ouais là il se stresse grave comme
dit Toka
il lui reste quoi il lui reste 5 cours à
jouer donc en fait ça va parce que s'il
fait Kais 4 cavalier 3
mais tu vas faire une dingue grille
ouais là il peut faire une dingue enfin
bon
et on demande si torcer cette ça gagne
pour 7 c'est Dame G5 toujours pareil
tu vas pas laisser ça quand même
c'est un compagnie
il me fait peur là je commence à flipper
non mais des fois
il a quand même une bonne
comme tout à l'heure la quantité des
jeux tour à trois
[Musique]
visuellement moi je pensais que ça gagne
effectivement
il veut bouger son fou faire dame B2
avancer le pion peut-être
on va faire sa défense à lui que ce fait
OK
ça c'est forcé en fait
à deux et en plus
il a vraiment ce truc quand il est moins
bien c'est vrai que ça
il a jamais réfléchi en fait
il impose
il impose Yann
en fait il cherche les tricks je pense à
ce moment-là
mais il y a plus de ouais il cherche il
cherche 4 il y a plus de trucs
stratégiques ou de
après ça marche ça lui rapporte aussi
des résultats de temps en temps hein oui
si tu as l'impression autant un moment
peut-être t'as pas de bien forcer tu
penserais tu te fous mal autant tu
t'énerves il te plante je sais pas enfin
c'est une manière de faire bon je
n'arrive pas trop à faire pour moi-même
mais
cavalier A3 donc à trois c'est un peu
particulier
ça c'est logique
exactement mais bon tu vois il y a plus
que quatre couilles à 11 minutes
c'est pas les plus dures tu vas mettre
une torsade c'était manger tu vas te
mettre derrière le pion
et puis tu auras de quoi faire bon tu
vas tu vas trouver quoi
ouais ça devrait bien se passer pour
Ding
puis là 11 minutes ça va c'est pas foutu
trop trop mal
zéro exactement alors il y en aura après
le 6e mais c'est un cas de figure qu'on
a pas encore vu dans le match
on n'est pas parti pour voir aujourd'hui
pas de nul avant de 40e enfin pas de
proposition de nul alors en 40e si tu
répètes trois fois la même position ou
qui a pas tout ou je sais pas quoi il y
a nul il est nul
mais
[Musique]
tu as le droit de te proposer
quand même que les chances de victoire
de Ding sont supérieures à 90% là non
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup d'atouts quoi donc ça
devrait bien se passer
ouais là ça devrait aller ça devrait
aller mais Yann qui réfléchit en salle
de repos il vient pas réfléchir sur
l'échiquier
même la gagne avec les Blancs celle-là
les gens me prennent vraiment pour un
Belin c'est incroyable quoi
c'est trop en fait
moi je la gagne je la gagne ici les amis
j'ai pas besoin de cette position cette
position là me suffit c'est trop
ah il me prennent vraiment pour des cons
pour un con c'est terrible
c'est bon les bols
parce qu'en long je peux la gagner voilà
je suis quand même confiant de la gagner
oui normalement enfin après
ça serait pas 100% mais un beau taux de
réussite non 100% non mais je suis là je
suis confiant
après faut pas que je stresse
bon c'est le problème toujours
la grosse contre Yann la grosse faudrait
essayer
prochain livre on préparation bah ouais
enfin il y a le livre qui sort le 25 mai
normalement
le livre le livret enfin je sais pas
comment on l'appelle mais 80 pages 80
pages voilà un livre Rooney un livreur
comme livret comme Cayet comme prendre
le terme qu'on veut est-ce qu'on peut
l'utiliser comme papier chiotte oh il
m'arrête un peu plus je pense
un papier
tu peux qui peut agrémenter vos chiottes
moi je voyais de livres de voyage tu
prends le train tu prends l'avion
livre de plage
de vacances
il sera pour quel niveau
jusqu'à 1800 ouais après les deux
exercices sont un peu durs enfin parce
que enfin c'est quand même un livre pas
que tu l'ouvres tu trouves la solution
en trois secondes à 3 ans 3 secondes bon
ben tu as lu le livre 10 minutes tu as
tout fait quoi donc oui au début ça
commence très gentil mais en fait chaque
fois il y a des petits couilles des
petits machins donc j'ai même quelqu'un
de vraiment bon il peut il peut le faire
pour le faire quoi
c'est tous les combien de temps les
championnats du monde à deux ans ou
trois ans c'est deux ans normalement
ouais mais sauf que là en fait à cause
du covid ça a complètement décalé il
fait fout bien
[Musique]
menace qui plane
à 3 ouais et là ok il faudra réfléchir
un peu
et là alors dit lui il gagne comment il
gagne un cavalier 7 6
en G6 et AG bon ça ça va pas être joué
je t'annonce
quoi
et d'un mètre carré moi je rentrerai
dans cette finale en fait très très
franchement
pour du bien pour du mal j'aurais ça
carrière sur dame B2 j'ai l'impression
que il prend F6 et je menace 7 non
mais enfin
tu peux aller là-dedans
du prochain ça peut être d'un fiable et
ceux qui est B4
tu fais cavalier
donc tu peux faire ça tu peux faire ça
et réfléchir et après tu as une heure
es qui a eu 7 façons il doit bouger sa
tour tu reviens il repart il reparti
très bien
donc peu importe mais bon tu auras ça
non c'est mieux on attaque le pion là
il fait ça ça
et pour B7
inutile quoi
ouais et puis en plus ça a calculé après
ouais mais bon
ça va bien se passer
mais bon non mais ok on sait jamais
franchement
non mais l'autre c'était très clair
quand tu vois une ligne qui va au 40e tu
sais que ça doit gagner et après tu
réfléchis bien quoi
et tu finis
et on fait la pause
voilà
mais là l'avantage c'est que il y a peu
de
moyens de rater je crois qu'en fait
toutes les ventes marchent
toi qui choisissent ça va aller moi j'ai
pour nous en terme de lui le sait pas
mais nous on le sait
quand même
si tu te doutes
tu dois te douter même si tu doutes
tu stresses
alors oui mais c'est rare
il y avait un Fisher spaski mais c'est
enfin les conditions de jeux sont
tellement enfin tout est tellement
bizarre dans ce match je crois qu'il y a
eu un carpoque aussi qui était très
chaud
fais voir je vais regarder un peu
donc le 78
[Musique]
craming 2006
il y a un forfait dans les deux matchs
[Musique]
non ça a commencé doucement après midi
victoire à droite à gauche c'est rare
ici en fait ça a commencé par genre 7
nulle mais d'un coup ça c'est enflammé
il y a beaucoup de bien beaucoup de
trucs
[Musique]
six minutes il fait tour à 7 logique
à 3 ça va partir à tempo à mon avis
[Musique]
OK et là bon on lui conseille le check
pour
récupérer du temps
et tiens tu peux faire tourner 8 juste
pour pas te laisser revenir je reviens
quand même et donc
[Musique]
en fait quand même parce que
ok bon ça va tout va alors
il y a pas mais surtout que là c'est
déjà le 39e donc en fait si tu fais
qu'il y a eu 7 et qui fait tour D8 toute
façon tu as une heure pour trouver ce
que tu dois trouver
ça fait plaisir
bon après peut-être que il va jouer
n'importe quoi avant
on fera la petite pause après ce coup
40e notre petite respiration
cavaliers
on a bien on a bien senti
et il se barre
professionnel là il récupère son heure
1h04 maintenant 40e coup ok bon ma
petite pause ça sonne
on sait qu'il va jouer vite on sait
ouais de toute façon ce serait beau qui
tank là une demi-heure non là il va
jouer vous voulez faire votre pause non
elle a le 40e qui fait du bien pour Ding
quel match
je voyais vraiment pas revenir au score
mais oui
sans parler de match mais dans les temps
à l'élite il y a pas autant de victoire
non il y a plein de nuls quoi
bon là en fait ils sont très motivés en
même temps et l'un et l'autre évidemment
donc ça change aussi beaucoup de belles
parties
tu vas tu joues pour aller chercher un
truc gros quoi
mais genre les candidats c'est un peu le
même truc où ils sont très motivés
vraiment gros c'est plus que candidats
mais déjà au candidats c'est hyper rare
une journée entière avec que des nuls
quoi
sur le tournoi mais pas
mais c'est marrant qu'il se mette à
réfléchir maintenant
c'est le moment où j'attendais le moins
la réflexion
ouais mais là oui c'est vrai qu'il
réfléchit sur
des change avec les Blancs imagine
c'était 24 parties ouais bah il devrait
un peu revenir sur sur la même truc
j'imagine des fois
autant que 24 secondes chacun
il en faut plus qu'une il en faut 10
enfin je sais pas comment dire
ce serait beau de faire ça en fait ton
engagement 24 en fait
tu les élimines tu fais un peu un Top
Chef des idées des idées des secondes je
suis une minute aussi alors vous avez
une heure pour vous préparez une
nouveauté
voilà les contraintes de l'épreuve
réfuter la berlinoise bon et puis tu
super vite quoi il te donne leur petite
prépa tu goûtes non c'est de la merde
manque de sauce
ça va pas
master secondaire
[Musique]
prochain stage
on fait un master secondant
il tape dessus quoi
c'était vraiment pas un métier fait pour
toi
cauchemar en prépa
ouvertures toutes ces parties se fait
défoncer
et montrera ce que tu joues contre le
London
c'est pas possible ça jamais vu ça quoi
hyper pousser si fuite dans le match je
prends des ouvertures que le gamepa
ouais mais c'est juste qu'il faut ouais
c'est pas c'est très difficile à faire
en fait
le deviner c'est pas facile il va pas te
le dire j'aime pas ça
faut qu'à toi ça te plaise faut que ce
soit pas forcé parce qu'en fait même
s'il n'aime pas que la prend tout par
cœur il va te la sécher et
puis il faut que toi tu puisses bien la
jouer quand même
donc c'est très difficile à faire mais
c'est très efficace
en plus ça c'était le London c'était
vraiment invisible parce qu'il ne joue
pas tellement souvent
mais le truc c'est quand même
tu peux t'y attendre donc tu es obligé
de le fermer et
c'était pas fermé en fait quoi
ouais mais après c'est catalan catalan
quoi mais ce que disait blague en fait
Magnus il a vraiment voulu faire en
match qui fait pas toujours en partie ce
qu'il a vraiment voulu dans l'ouverture
ciblée un truc et à la maison
ça finit par marcher mais ça aurait pu
très mal tourné
de faire la petite pause pour nous les
amis
parce que ça va là ça va un peu
temporiser il y a plein d'options
pour éviter une fois mais il est pas du
tout obligé 6 bon il va calculer ça
devrait gagner donc on se retrouve
dans quelque chose comme une dizaine de
minutes les amis à tout de suite
pour le dénouement de cette sixième
partie du match de championnat du monde
à toute
[Musique]
ok on est de retour
le journal aujourd'hui
ça marche
ok
cette partie d'aujourd'hui avec le roman
tellement célèbre de
crime et le chantier
[Musique]
et puis après après très peu d'exception
le reste de la partie les Blancs ont
joué sur les cases noires
d'ailleurs maintenant moi un peu
témoigner que le cavalier sur E7 la dame
est sur jee3 la tour est sur A7 le roi
est sur H2 et les plus et les pions
centraux sur Citroën de 4 voilà faut pas
affaiblir les cases noires
sinon
je sais pas en fait
je sais que le coup qui gagne sûrement
et c'est pas les points de calculer
cette cavalier
pour vous enfoncer le coup comme ça et
puis après toutes les taxis vont marcher
plus tard d'ailleurs
si jamais les Noirs vont pas faire gaffe
oui et par exemple la dame bouge quelque
part il y aura des idées comme
[Musique]
ce set
pardon j'ose par le plaisir esthétique
d'amour 4 avec
n'importe quoi plus ou moins bien sûr il
y a d'autres coups qui gagnent plus
facilement je suppose
que tu es complètement assure que ça
gagne donc pourquoi pas quoi ok ok le
faux sur la diaganale bois H7 tellement
minable encore plus minable que son
proprio quoi
que
il est un petit peu dommage bien sûr de
les changer mais bon il y a des
concessions à faire dans les parties
après voilà je vois l'ordi lui il aime
bien ça pour je pense venir là et mater
ah ça par contre il faut voir parce que
moi j'ai pas vu l'aider en fait
et dis-moi sinon Fab d'après toi
la Torré sur un 7 la Tourette est sur un
seul d'après toi que c'est facile ou pas
il fait quoi il fait dame j'ai 5 pardon
et si moi je bouffe je bouge sur je sais
juste une question de lambda comme il
veut faire à deux comme ça et oui OK je
retourne avec le cavalier
parce que d'après ce que je sais aux
échec une fois les Noirs ont une telle
formation comme le fou sur Brown et le
pion sur A2
il y a pas moyen totalement le pire en
fait parce que pour cela aller à la tour
de doit arriver à la première mais il va
jamais y arriver parce que le fou jeune
donc
alors une autre technique pour gagner en
fait nous on pensait tu vois parce que
c'était ça la position juste avant que
même ça en fait pour faire pour faire la
Finale
4 non
je suppose
essayons
c'est tellement facile en fait c'est
juste les pieds en bouche
[Rires]
et comme ça jusqu'à la 9e jusqu'à le 10e
mais peut-être que c'est encore mieux
maintenant je sais pas
bon il est vrai de bouffer le encore un
pion c'est c'est comme ça peut paraître
comme quoi un petit peu trop gourmand
parce que
comme ça le cavalier se loin de l'action
il vient de jouer de 500
couleurs je pense j'ai essayé de
répondre c'est à simplifier
bon ok un jour agressif dans un 5
différents par rapport au miam
j'aime pas trop ce que je vois avec
l'ordi c'est que je regarde les
évaluations là il donne bon dame c'est
ça gagnant
mais pourquoi pas ça du coup et 40
dis-moi alors si après des cinq à dos
dans ce 7 gagne et au lieu de 200 que si
un jour tout de suite
notons que dames 5 pierre après que les
justices oui
[Musique]
pour le futur alors c'est quoi le cours
alors après dans ce set sur le courant
ok ça se comprend et hop pourquoi après
ça gagne si facilement dans ce set et
maintenant
oh [__] il prend la case il veut faire
dame prend tour
il veut
il a pris la case E6 et comme ça elle
menace dame jouit
que s'il le voit qu'il est architecte
pourquoi changer ça
hyper beau par contre
c'est aussi beau peut-être si vous vous
rappelez de rappel de
de la dernière partie
kasparo
dans le troisième manche les géométrie
non non les géométrie de la troisième
match
ok 86
belles géométrie avec la dame et le
cavalier
ça c'est hyper beau bien sûr mais par
contre ça me rend heureux quoi
ok si il fait dame C7 bravo quoi super
fin l'autre a déjà joué à deux
ça risque de bien sûr
par contre
quoi que ok je le critique mais en fait
moi aussi parfois je fais le con en
train de chercher les MASTER peace quand
c'était complètement gagnant je fais
exactement les mêmes photos d'habitude
c'est une faute
ok ça peut être expliqué que peut-être
il cherche de rentrer dans l'histoire de
l'échiquier
plus que de gagner ce match en fait
alors
presque 45 minutes compteur 1 minute 19
et maintenant donc est-ce que on va
témoigner un moment historique ou
bien une tragédie personnelle
exactement et les points sur l'échiquier
bon je pense qu'il va la voir mais
sinon ça fait débile des cinq
il y a pas de raison alors dams c'est 37
dame F7 pas de coupe parce que j'ai 8
arrive mesdames et messieurs
dans ce cas-là nous tous on peut dire
que
ouais
est-ce que souvent ce sentiment tu as
été là quoi
non pas si souvent non
moi ce sentiment deux fois dans ma vie
peut-être ça a été alors pendant la 24e
partie de Kasparov carpro deuxième match
et alors la dernière partie du troisième
match c'est là d'aujourd'hui
sinon non plus jamais ni avant ni après
avant le contrôle
à un moment donné
quoi juste carrément trembler il a il a
regardé son fichier regardez les
positions
regardez les positions par contre il
faut tout ce qu'il a fallu faire et il
est il est exécuté le coup dont vous
aviez parlé de toi
la caméra des joueurs mais j'avais
l'impression qu'il jouait parce qu'il
bougeait
il voit il voit donc bientôt on va tous
se dire nous nous dire un hôtel
optimiste Fab c'est que si après une
réflexion pas trop longue il voit ça une
géométrie
paradoxale comme ça c'est que peut-être
il se remet en forme quand même pour le
pour la suite du match
donc il voit oui ça y est il va exécuter
les premières fois un impôts a perdu
en serrant le monde de son adversaire et
les pousser un petit sourire oui est-ce
qu'il va le faire aujourd'hui ça
m'étonnerait
donc ce qu'il veut se faire échec au roi
au coup d'après et la me prendre de
cette main donc peut-être pour les
spectateurs qui ont les justices
intercepte
beaucoup plus simple
tour Eiffel dame sur les huitième tout
bêtement il est là-bas oui donc il en
reste quoi il reste que wash7 alors ça
il y a plus d'échec donc les Noirs ils
se disent bah il enlève son cavalier je
défends
ce qui est le cas et donc ouais toute la
pointe c'est qu'il y a ça appelons les
choses comment ils sont il a trouvé les
victoires à la garée c'est carrément à
la gare
et maintenant il veut manger et même sur
ça ça marche toujours quoi
le même ah tiens ce
et si il mange pas le cavalier qui fait
je sais pas ce qu'il veut ça tu vois
ça c'est ça merde il défend
piège quoi
non mais bon ok un autre coup je sais
pas ça
et tout l'importance du pion c'est là il
peut pas partir s'enfuir il faut aussi
noter que
pour l'attaque mais aussi il est top si
jamais pour défendre la case F4 la case
éternelle des perpète aux échecs en
général y compris dans ce quartier il y
a eu beaucoup de variantes pour voyage à
chaque fois
donc
incroyable ce match
il y avait beaucoup de pronostics
sceptiques par contre ça tourne
peut-être le meilleur match pour le
Coran depuis très très longtemps depuis
très très longtemps en fait on n'a pas
eu un tel match combatif ok nous on se
moque parfois de joueurs mais comment
dire
soyez repos soit aujourd'hui dingue bah
un peu critiquer les vainqueurs mais pas
trop sinon les parties sont assez
exemplaire
bon maintenant il ne reste que alors
suivre
le spectacle de des expressions
physiques
sinon les parties va se terminer au bout
d'une minute
plus vite maman en fait je donne
de 20 à 30 secondes
oui oui
et
yes
[Musique]
je sais plus à quoi m'attendre en fait
seule chose paradoxale un petit peu
c'est que il gagnait sur les cases
noires cases noires cases noires mais
les deux derniers coups sont les cases
y compris
sauf où je suis sa gérant
un peu
ouais je sais pas
je pense qu'il va rester combien de
temps à contempler le désastre
j'ai prévu au 30 secondes déjà je pense
que c'est autour de notre quelque part
bah vas-y donne-moi ton crabe
qu'est-ce que tu penses
bon il a pas l'air trop surpris kanding
la jouer en tout cas quand je regarde
félicitations à tous ceux qui ont noté
pour dire que voilà ok
en fait le match
surpasser les pronostics les plus
populaires les plus optimistes tu es
parti
mais je suis content du match quoi
d'accord bon alors dans ce cas là à part
de vous ceux qui sont pour dingue je
félicite alors moi-même
intéressant qu'il sera son prochain idée
avec les Blancs pour avoir du jour pour
sortir de
des théoriques et plus ou moins de le
même style parce que c'est sûr que il va
nous à leur proposer une quatrième idée
du même genre
pour cette phase finale de la partie
j'en ai un peu réfléchi mais j'ai pas
compris j'ai pas trouvé d'idées donc je
veux pas faire les pronostics mais il va
sortir encore une petite ligne
pour peut-être nous proposer une autre
symphonie des cases noires ou des cases
blanches
bon la bonne journée à tous Demain c'est
journée de repos on se retrouve mardi yo
yo yo la fin de fleurs